so connor was like it's 20 minutes home
on a comfy taxi
so then we get in the taxi taxi's
driving fine and
then just some random police officer
just walks out onto the street and kind
of
flags us down there's like four
policemen surround this like old
poor old man yeah and i asked the taxi
driver i'm like
something wrong and he's like i was
speeding
hello and welcome to another episode of
trash taste
i am your host once again gant and with
me
are the boys as per usual yup
how are you boys doing good it's the
first week we've skipped of recording a
trash taste yeah
it felt weird it felt like my it felt
weird like
because normally we record on tuesdays
people probably figured this out
like i don't know how you figured out
like tr some people have figured out the
entire trash taste schedule
mentioned it in passing yeah what we
think is a passing comment people
like remember i remember i got a tweet
as well i was randomly
checking twitter like right before about
to start and someone tweeted at me
saying like what are you going to talk
about today joey
i was just like where are you
you're watching me yeah and people have
figured out like some like the recording
order as opposed to like the airing
order as well there's probably like a
watch order
the official trash taste watch order
somewhere on reddit i don't know yeah
because some of them
get mixed around right yeah sponsors and
whatnot but yeah
in general you could figure out based on
who's sitting where
yeah yeah normally in general
unfortunately god doesn't have a guest
today
i'm a little sad about that this is my
second
podcast in a row without a guess 2021 is
different it feels good it feels like a
weight's been lifted off my shoulder you
know
wow i'm suddenly calling all i guess
no i'm just i'm just here i've just got
the space by myself on the table and
it's just good it's good to be on the
hosting side
see you're lucky right that you weren't
[ __ ] hosting with chris cause he kept
making me down things i wasn't sitting
next time
come on come on drink it come on to be
fair you're a [ __ ] drinking that sucker
i wouldn't make it
yeah i would have done the exact same
thing tastes like [ __ ] and you know i'm
not gonna be forced to consume something
that tastes like [ __ ]
this is for a challenge and i lose then
it's my fault right
so how are you enjoying your christmas
holiday boys well that's when we're
recording this right yes
we are recording this during the
christmas holidays we've we've had our
christmas episodes but uh we are
enjoying our christmas holidays right
now even though we're still technically
working
i took two days off and then i was like
right a whole two days back back to it
then
back to youtube i don't know i i really
i even like going one day without
youtube i'm like [ __ ] i want to do
something
yeah i want to make something yeah i
want to entertain i want to be a clown
i don't know why you're a clown every
day it's all right i think yeah there's
pretty some deep
insecurity that happened during my
childhood that makes me strive to want
to entertain i don't know why but
yeah i don't know it was nice it was fun
i it's nice having actually i think
what the difference between like a
holiday that is everyone's holiday
yeah and one that you set for yourself
is that when it's like a like a national
holiday you're like well [ __ ] i have to
i guess
yeah yeah yeah yeah you're like
obligated yeah yeah but then sometimes
you know you're not your headspace isn't
it you're like man i kind of want to
take a vacation but like i don't want to
but then when if you do it yourself you
hype yourself up for it you're like i'm
taking this time off no one's going to
tell me what to do but on christmas
you're like [ __ ] i kind of want to like
i don't want to like make a video i want
to [ __ ] around yeah i don't know what it
is about the christmas holidays i've
well i've always ended up working during
the christmas holidays because i've had
my yearly videos that probably won't
happen this year but
that's probably that's mostly what i'm
working on during the christmas holidays
um and then i've realized that
you know as youtubers you need to take a
[ __ ] break right yeah yeah and yeah
it feels i don't know what it is but do
you ever get
you know sometimes we take breaks during
the weekdays right to us we don't like
weekends don't technically exist but i
found that
taking breaks on the weekends feels a
lot better than taking breaks
in during the weekdays because it just
feels nice when you know that
everyone else in the country is on a
break as well you know
well except for most hand where yeah
yeah except in japan where christmas day
is just a regular workout yeah yeah and
also weekends are a suggestion
to stop working yeah they're not
enforced every holiday is a suggestion
let's be honest i went up to uh to
the north of japan for about three or
four days to go see chris
yeah um and that was really nice there's
so much [ __ ] snow
did he make you drink shitty sacking uh
no he made me drink good suck
oh yeah and also that's an oxymoron for
connor though yeah
also it was the first time ever i did
like a proper japanese christmas aka kfc
how was it it's just kfc this is
exactly what i thought it's just chicken
like it's it's just like a trip to kate
although it was kind of weird because
chris had to
schedule it like or book it book kfc
king kfc yeah we have to watch the world
come to
like two two or three weeks in advance
right and it's also weird it's not just
like a
you not only have to book it but you
have to book like a day in time to go
and pick it up
yeah as well so it's like not only do
you have to come in on debt on a certain
day to a certain store but it's like
come between a 2 to 3 p.m time bracket
right
and this and we went there and there was
just like a group of about maybe like
five or six families just lining up to
get their christmas chicken from the
colonel and i
would rather die than line up for a
chaos yeah and i mean you know it was
like what
we got like a full bucket of like just a
bunch of chicken wings
as you do but also at the bottom of the
bucket there was like this
kind of christmas cake or like christmas
pudding right
i don't know because i don't think
anyone had a slice of it but it was at
the bottom of the thing we're like oh
that's
a little weird that it's just been
sitting underneath this like greasy
greasy [ __ ] chicken that's no way
you'd want to put a cake no
it was the last thing we were expecting
at the bottom of the the bucket to be
fair
and uh it was like 5 000 yen for it and
it could feed maybe about
three or four people you paid 50 bucks
for kfc
on christmas yeah oh my god i mean i
didn't kristen you could have had a nice
roast dinner for that oh no we ordered
all the food as well okay
but we were like just because it was the
first time for all of us we've never had
a japanese christmas before
so we're like you know what [ __ ] it
let's do it and uh wouldn't do it again
to be honest it's just
it's just kfc isn't it i just go wrong
because the thing is
like this is i think the fourth year
that i've been in
asia celebrating christmas and i gotta
say i you don't
really understand the entire the entire
like height behind this
oh the the christmas spirit you know
yeah i thought that was just like
i thought that was just my [ __ ] meme
it's just a marketing point yeah yeah
yeah
i didn't understand that until i started
spending christmas outside of you know
where you know countries that normally
celebrate christmas
and you know you can do a lot of things
to make it feel christmassy but having
spent a few christmas
christmases in asia i kind of miss that
christmas spirit because
there's there's a few things you know
you can put on the christmas songs and
you can do whatever you know put up the
tree
but there's just something missing i
can't put my finger on it but it just
doesn't feel fully christmassy i think
it just has to do with the fact that at
least in japan
christmas is not a family thing yeah
it's like a romantic thing
yeah and also everyone's working so it's
like yeah yeah like i got a delivery
on like as we were having our roast
dinner and it was like the least
it was like the immersion breaking
christmas right the moment where
simulation ruined yeah yeah i had an
amazon package and i was like this is
not christmas that's the door on your
red hat
like i i refuse to have this wine in
hand
yeah christmas simulation over it was
like that rick and morty episode where
you're just trapped in an ultimate like
like this this like reality yeah is it
like to me
christmas is like going back and
reluctantly having to talk to family
members about like oh i do youtube you
know this is what i yeah
naked online yeah yes i make this much
per year thank you uncle for asking me
for the seventh time
you're investing right in the pension
right yes yes i am
no i don't know yeah i don't know it
felt it felt odd because i feel like
normally
i didn't i didn't appreciate christmas
that much because i didn't realize that
it was a really good way of like
in my head at least i don't know if this
is because i've been this is how i
taught
it was like this is the end of the year
yeah now now go and restart it
and then build up to all of this again
because it was it's not just christmas
it's that period between christmas
christmas and new year's yeah that is
just like
the blank period we don't do anything
where it's just like what rules
what what are the rules nobody knows
what's going on are the buses running i
don't know are the trains running
our shops open it's [ __ ] anarchy and
i love that period because it's
google how how long can i have leftovers
for
how many christmas dinners yeah that's
that was like
living in england that was like one of
my favorite parts of the year
it was just it was just as you said like
the reset of the year it was like the
entirety the entire society was just
kind of goes into cooldown right yeah
yeah exactly right whereas here it's
like
businesses business as usual like
supermarkets and convenience stores are
open
literally 24 7. even on new year's day
my mum won't shut up about kfc christmas
to me she's
fascinated by it she's like i heard they
have kfc for christmas is it true and
i'm like yes they do mom it's like wow
how crazy is that and i'm like yeah it's
kind of weird
it's too fair it is bizarre yeah it is
weird it's like
you know just all the things that japan
has
no interest in from like the west right
yeah we bring our finest things they're
like no no none of that none of that
and then suddenly the colonel rocks up
and he's like listen how about let me
picture this like greece
let me take this absolutely nothing to
do with christmas food and somehow make
it christmas food
who did like oh my god like how do they
pull this off like i'm sure someone
knows the history behind it but like to
me even if you explained to me how it
was done
yeah the kfc marketing department did
this i mean i explained it to you last
time right but even then it
still doesn't make sense to me it's like
i researched it and it doesn't make
sense
it was like the marketing heist of the
century like i swear in japan like just
normal marketing things they just don't
care about that like advertisements
everywhere
don't care about that oh oh there's a
collaboration where i can get my
favorite character
poorly printed on a latte oh well a
hundred bucks hello
that drives me insane dude when you see
it on paper it just sounds like a great
pretender episode
how do they pull this off this is like
heist five now this is like the ova
episode man
when they sell christmas to the japanese
actually like it is it's [ __ ] it's
like some ocean's 11 [ __ ] with every
marketing department and like
they they do collaborations with stuff
so this is a really common thing japan
where
they don't just market things normally
you can't have adverts it's like you
have to collaborate with businesses
yeah like i went to the supermarket and
i saw like washing detergent
there's like a bungo stray dogs
collaboration oh yeah we got one with
levi on it yeah and i was like
okay levi that makes sense yeah but like
some shows it's like why
why does bongo stray dogs have a
collaboration with washing detergent to
be fair
it works i'm a weeb it works i see i see
like i see evangelion i see oscar's face
plus
plastered on some coffee i'm like i need
no no no no this is why i hate it
because
to me right you don't go to a fine
dining like restaurant for example right
yeah and they
they draw a [ __ ] smiley face on your
hamburger you'd be insulted wouldn't you
you'd be like no no no where's my steak
why is there a smiley on it
this is the way i see stuff and like if
you put like characters on it or you put
like
[ __ ] smiley faces i hate it when
disneyland does that by the way when
they put [ __ ] smiley faces on your
food
it's like what is my food a joke to you
i want to eat it [ __ ] okay never mind
i'm gonna get it off around
but like to me you're making the product
seem more childish by putting stuff on
it so when i see these collaborations
like most the time with like especially
with the animes at the cafes i'm like
this is all disgusting right you're
selling me a three dollar latte for 10
times the price
i mean i'm offended i mean i feel like
it's just it's it's very similar to what
they do in the west with celebrities but
like
you know you don't get like a kim
kardashian latte um
didn't travis scott just do like a
[ __ ] collaboration with mcdonald's
i wasn't that insanely like successful
as well yeah but wait okay first of all
i'm near certain correct me if i'm wrong
they didn't plaster his like face on it
i'm pretty sure they had like a specific
menu
and i thought okay fine yeah it's ten
dollars by the way yeah
which is [ __ ] ridiculous yeah but
with stuff like that but you have to
understand that
the fans will pay any amount of money
right for that one photo right right
right so then i i you know i go i go
to have it and i gotta drink it and then
as i drink this latte
like this film of like the plastic [ __ ]
that they printed it
goes in my mouth and i'm like like god
it's disgusting
it's vile i i don't have to peel [ __ ]
off my coffee
to eat it so i'm here scooping it out
ruining this picture they printed on it
yeah yeah and i just ended up hating all
of it i don't care how much for a fan i
am of something i don't want that [ __ ]
printed on my food i mean that's kind of
on you then for going to that cafe right
like you could have easily just gone to
starbucks right here yeah that's the
thing is if you go to the exhibition or
whatever you go to these things i don't
mean not that like there's like enough
there if you're a fan right but yeah
like you have to you have to obligatory
go to the gift shop on the cafe because
you know yeah of course you have to and
you know the gift shop sometimes has
some good stuff but some stuff that i
don't
care about like they're obsessed with
making coasters of characters
yeah it's it's it's not just the
coasters i've noticed that as well
because
it's they they're putting gacha into it
as well because the blind box
so if you want to collect the character
you actually like you gotta you gotta
buy more [ __ ] right you gotta buy
an extra meal because that was exactly
the same thing as when i went to the
fate museum as well
and it's like being a kid all over again
with the the happy meal toys
yeah yeah man i remember one time i like
i
really there burger king were doing this
collaboration with like spongebob toys
and i was like mom listen this is the
third i need to go destroy this is the
third patrick star i've had mom can you
please go and do like a karen thing and
get me the the other toy
yeah my my parents used to do that all
the time you would always go up and ask
but sometimes they'd be like no
really yeah i've never heard of someone
saying no yeah really yeah
they're usually just like whatever i
don't get paid enough yeah yeah exactly
right
it's like i don't control the gotcha
it's a [ __ ] guarantee i don't care i
get paid six dollars an hour i'm just
give it to you
but yeah i just i'm not a big fan of the
collaboration cafes i just feel like
you don't really get that good of an
experience of the show i feel like the
collaboration cafes
are a bit [ __ ] a bit tactical a bit
tacky
no yes it's tacky like which i i feel
like most anime cafes are
like that i've never been i've met never
been to like an anime cafe and been
impressed by it
because no it's it's like you go in this
room that's like a normal sized cafe and
you're like oh
they've just plastered paintings of the
characters in the shows on the wall
wow look at this like they don't even
get creative with it like i i would say
i've been to quite a few because aki
likes to do videos
yeah but i'd say the only i've only ever
been to two collaborative cafes where i
was just like i would go back and that's
the pokemon cafe and the kirby cafe
but that's just because nintendo has
just so much bigger of a budget
yeah that they can afford to get a
little more creative with it right yeah
yeah there's so many of them you go and
watch a youtube video of someone like
going to a cafe
and it's like you could see these
youtubers desperately trying to get like
seven minutes out of this cafe yeah at
the end of the day it's just like it's
literally just paintings on a wall yeah
i went to the weathering with you cafe
and that [ __ ] was so
[ __ ] it's because it's the same
formula every time
and you if you like if you come to japan
come to like one anime cafe
and then realize that that's that's the
experience for every cafe you know that
you the way i see it is that you come
once as a tourist and you're like
that was cool yeah and then you just
don't go to any others because they're
all the same
no no i was gonna say like also how they
get you with all these like anime cafes
is that they
they're only open for limited amounts of
time right because they would [ __ ]
make money
yeah there's a sense of urgency where
it's like oh the promised netherlands
cafe is only open for two weeks
yeah i mean i would promise neverland
let's go and then you go and you get
disappointed and before you can
file a complaint it's it's gone the food
was vile as well oh yeah
it's all microwaved food or whatever the
kirby cafe that had some really good
food
i was like i was like i was actually
like wow i've never had someone be like
you must try this souffle you must you
must go to the square innings
collaboration cafe for the best it's
like
because it's not like going to the jojo
bar where there was obviously like a fan
of jojo who like
personalized these cocktails
it's all sponsored it's all corporate
businessmen stamping like
yes collaboration yeah what can we do
coasters
let's print the character on a latte and
put some anime posters up
and then sell a bunch of clear files i
realize you're probably like
like breaking so many dreams right now
by explaining how [ __ ] they are
listen if you come here on a like a
visiting you'll probably find it
interesting if there's a show you really
like but in general
yeah like like the cafe is always the
lowest point to any like big anime event
because i went
i went to the faye cafe but that was the
fake cafe
in the fate museum and the museum the
exhibition actually
was [ __ ] awesome oh yeah yeah yeah
because you got to see the entire
[ __ ] history of this franchise
like of not just fake but like the
entire like type moon universe and
everything yeah yeah yeah yeah
see that's cool if it's like a like
because i went to the corner super cafe
yeah but that was in par with the corner
super movie
yeah so you you can only go to this cafe
if you bought tickets to the movie yeah
so
that was like okay you know it's like a
little bonus thing but i wouldn't go all
the way to central tokyo
to go to a [ __ ] corner no no no it's
just not worth it like i i definitely
wouldn't recommend going to any pop-up
cafes if something's limited time then
they have not put effort into it no no
dude the
the best cafe i went to is actually like
the one i made a video on which is like
the
3d latte art yeah that cafe is so
[ __ ] good i went to suck your own
dick there
just like yeah i must say the only good
cafe i've been to is the one that i made
i wouldn't make a video on if i didn't
think it was good right like yeah but
that again that's like a permanent cafe
that's right yeah that's bad because you
can literally the best part about that
thing is you can take in like anything
that you want you're like
make it 3d yeah like they'll find a way
to do it it's so [ __ ] cool
also that guy on twitter shitpost like
crazy the owner is so good
so funny yeah that's the thing it's like
again like again the reason why i like
the pokemon cafe and the kirby cafe so
good is because they're permanent yeah
they're also
every every season they're like oh we
can bring out something a little bit
more experimental if it doesn't work
take it out yeah nintendo are really
good at doing like i mean have you seen
the
the the new uh theme park they're
releasing yeah yeah yeah it's opening
february right my god i saw that i saw a
picture of that i thought wow legoland's
really improved
i didn't think it was real at first
think we've talked about that okay so i
watched the video of uh
uh what's the guy's name shigeru mimoto
oh yeah like having a tour of it
and you get like a bracelet that you can
like hit [ __ ] with and like there's like
keys and stuff
really dude it looks badass yeah like i
felt like a 10 year old watching him
like talk about it i'm like yeah
sorry i saw a japanese youtuber who got
like first access ever as a youtuber but
he's also been
it's in the japanese of course but he's
been sponsored by usj
and nintendo in the past he's literally
like japan's like youtuber oh he cooking
yeah yeah yeah because one time the
like i had a policeman that was asking
me like what do you do and i was like
youtuber he's like oh like hikakin
like no i'm not like hika i'm like yeah
yeah dude yeah whatever
like hikakin and youtuber are like
synonymous yeah yeah they're pretty much
strange but uh yeah what's the [ __ ]
we've never talked about yeah
so this is how you get tickets in japan
basically yeah
that's better than scalping let's go
what's golfing
scalping is people who buy a [ __ ] ton of
things and then just jump on prices
i mean people do that too i mean it's
just
it's it's in theory to stop that from
happening right
but like for example the when the
olympics for example uh
we don't know if that's going to be
happening next year but uh we've already
announced that it will be
yeah we'll see i reckon it'll happen no
matter what but it'll be interesting to
see how they'll do it yeah
exactly but like with the olympics for
example they did it it's so dumb so they
do a lottery
that you enter and it's like a lottery
to get a certain amount of tickets so
this is how we do it so like uh when i
went to the persona 5
uh concert yeah it was a lottery system
but it was really weird because it was
like
you go into the lottery to get a certain
number of tickets
and they're different lotteries so it's
like if you want to go just by yourself
you enter the lottery to get one ticket
but there's another lottery to get two
tickets or three tickets or four tickets
and just because you enter into one of
them it's not
guaranteed that you're gonna get those
tickets yeah but then
what it is is that you might think oh
okay so if you win the lottery
then you just get the tickets right no
you get the right to purchase the
tickets
japan have figured out a way to gachify
every process
possible man yeah i mean it's also i
also saw that you could get some of the
tickets but you could only be entered
into some of them if you bought like a
panasonic device
yeah yeah yeah they were like giving
away some of the tickets to i was like
what the [ __ ]
and also and also the shitty thing as
well is that like say you enter the
lottery to get four tickets right
but you're not sure if you're gonna get
it so you want to enter multiple times
but here's the kicker say you win twice
right in that four ticket lottery you're
forced to pay for those eight tickets
you can't back out of that [ __ ] like
you're actually forced like even if
it's only four people that you're going
with and you just did another lottery
for backup
you have to buy eight tickets it just it
just doesn't make sense to me it just
doesn't make sense i mean i
i i understand in theory why they do it
but i i feel like
this is this this is like trying to put
out a fire with cooking oil
you know what i mean it's just the most
roundabout [ __ ] time-consuming way
to do it and i guarantee nintendo line's
going to do the same thing
yeah probably i mean nintendo haven't
got the best rep at the moment
they've been like [ __ ] everything up
i can't believe that man
nintendo and dmca are like that right
now yeah with the stuff with the smash
tournament did you see that as well that
was a while back yeah yeah did you not
see that no i didn't see that
basically they like just uh cease and
desisted a big tournament they've been
going on for a while
and everyone was like the [ __ ] because
they were using um
um so the obviously the netcode of the
switch smash brothers is pretty garbage
yeah so people fan modded their own
version of it that's much better
oh it's called like slippy or something
and they didn't allow that and because
they were going to use
that it's called slippy yeah because it
like actually runs smoothly because
nintendo online sucks
yeah and always has sucked and the fact
they pay for it is kind of a joke yeah
um because you don't really get anything
out of it like it's awful it's so bad
like i love nintendo but god damn is
that online
sock yeah they're really going to fix
that and so they cease and desist of
them
and then they were also sponsoring a
splatoon tournament
right and guess how much the what guess
what the prize was for the so they were
giving the prize
like sanctioned event yeah they're
giving the top prize for a team of five
versus five was a
25 nintendo eshop gift card
and then oh my god they're dead they
they
they canceled the event because one of
the teams had something like
free smash or something it was like like
had something
along the lines of like nintendo over
there i'd like to for solidarity with
the smash bros
prize you can't even pay for whatever
you can't even split that you can't even
pay for the game
your [ __ ] tournament is it's just
funny because it's like
for some reason nintendo just wants
their [ __ ] eyepiece to die like i
don't get it dude
right games are sweating man they're
just like oh there's a new competitor in
the esports scene now
it's it's wild to me because you just
see the like the complete difference
again like you said riot right
yeah you have the [ __ ] what is it the
baron pat red bull pack
the red bull mercedes drive to victory
like they're fully embracing like
becoming sports and nintendo's like none
of that
games the state farm analyst desk god i
remember watching worlds this year
and it was so weird just seeing like
literally everything monitored it's
literally like watching
i say that drinking my g fuel out of my
g4
thank you for sponsoring trash taste
their meal and i said it
yeah it is it is funny how it's become
like american football where like
every single part of the game is like
sponsored and then you again you have
the complete opposite where nintendo's
like
yeah we don't want to put any of this
because because nintendo could make
money off it if they really wanted to
they only be in charge of this but they
just have no interest in it no i mean
you know
we've i mean they're probably already
making enough as is well that's that
that's the japanese mindset isn't it
yeah like we've made enough
doing it the way we like you don't want
to make more money yeah but like
i guess which is so odd for a business
to
say because i think what was it like
last year nintendo was the most
cash-rich company in japan yeah
which is insane i i i think there's
something is slightly wrong with that
statement it's not that they don't want
to make more money
because from like my experience working
with japanese money
japanese companies they want to make as
much money as possible that they but
they only
want to make as much money as possible
using the methods
it's not that they don't want to make
money is that they don't know how to
make money in other ways exactly
exactly because they like esports well i
think it's
i think it's where if you ask someone
like you know if you ask me connor you
can make
ten dollars guaranteed or connor you can
make a hundred dollars by you know
pushing yourself
being a little crazy and it might it
might might go horribly wrong of course
every time i'm gonna be like 100 bucks
let's do it yeah of course but
the japanese companies don't see it that
way yeah yeah japanese companies like
yeah there's one person in the company
that wants to get creative but he has to
ask 60 other people for yes
yeah you know and that might take a
while but by the time they always say
yeah our new trends come out
i get it because almost you know if
you're the you're the head of these
companies you don't want to
get make a hundred odd people lose that
job yeah right so you're getting a safe
route
but sometimes the safe route can just
lead to being stacked yeah but also it's
like how
detrimental could it be if like one
thing doesn't work out right like again
nintendo is the most cash rich company
in japan right it's like how much do
they have to lose
it sucks because you just everyone like
wants nintendo to just
do this [ __ ] yeah because everyone
[ __ ] loves everyone wants to
like [ __ ] scene into everyone's
cheering for nintendo just to do the
right thing yeah
you know what i mean it's literally the
opposite of like ea where everyone just
wants the a to keep [ __ ] up and keep
[ __ ] up to the point where laws have
to be made but with nintendo everyone
just wants to see
and it's it's like in the sh you know
you have those typical shows where
you know the brother is addicted to
drugs and the whole family is super nice
and he's like come on
just please stop just come on get get
back on your feet man come on
nintendo yeah how many chances do we
have to give you how many rehabs do we
need to put you through
to see you get back on track especially
after all the [ __ ]
w's that they were taking these last
couple of years yeah they were just like
killing every e3 everyone was like yep
nintendo king yeah exactly [ __ ]
everybody else and now they just like
we haven't had a nail in a while let's
let's let's give that a couple of them
people [ __ ] lost their [ __ ] when they
brought out literal cardboard like
like this is a company that can release
cardboard and we'll eat it up
like this this is how much all right
yeah yeah
i completely forgot about that yeah like
okay at the end of the day they do like
the coolest [ __ ] [ __ ] like they do
nintendo are just doing their own thing
man yeah like i played ring fit and i
was like
who what kind of crackhead came up with
this idea to like just [ __ ] exercise
with a ring
and like and it works and it's good like
who came up with this [ __ ]
this is insane we've never seen this
from any other company it's it seems
like creatively
they will take any [ __ ] risk possible
yeah but like on a business sense
they're like
no no we do not do business here yeah we
don't we only we only make things
business is not allowed this episode is
sponsored by expressvpn when you use the
bathroom you can always close the door
behind you right
no no no you never actually never do oh
my god
proud with the door open well [ __ ] that
kind of [ __ ] up the next line of this
but i'm gonna say it anyway you don't
want a random passerby looking in on you
unless you're these boys so why would
you let people look in on you when you
go online
using the internet without expressvpn is
like going to the bathroom
without closing your door that's a
nightmare did you know that your
internet service provider like comcast
verizon
knows every single website you visit i
didn't connor but thank you for letting
us know
and what's worse i'm told is that they
can sell this information to ad
companies and tech giants who will use
your data
to target you i don't believe it but
don't worry expressvpn can put a stop to
that it creates a secure encrypted
tunnel between your device and the
internet so that your online activity
can't be seen by anyone i use expressvpn
on all my devices it works on everything
phones laptops even routers so everyone
who shares your wi-fi and the best part
is using expressvpn is as easy as
closing the bathroom door
you just fire up the app click one
button and you're protected expressvpn
is the world's
number one rated vpn by cnet wyatt the
verge and countless others
so if you're like me believing your
online activity should be
your business like when you take a [ __ ]
secure yourself by visiting
expressvpn.com trash taste today
that's expressvpn.com trash taste where
you can get extra
three three months that's expressvpn.com
taste links down in the description
below i think i think the creative they
obviously trust their creative
people at nintendo and they obviously
let them do the crazy ideas like they
released the
mario kart like ar uh did you see that
yeah yeah basically like get your own rc
cars with cameras in them that can
oh no i saw that which is again another
[ __ ] call
okay yeah it's so cool and 99 people
can't do this because i don't have the
living room
actually i actually i actually do but i
mean most people come people
yeah i also the thought of having to put
a track down and then clean it up
yeah exactly i mean you know just the
whole concept of mario maker right
yeah that's like it's like clearly
they're embracing like their fans
creative side
yeah i love watching mario make your
videos yeah they're so cool
but no on the but but at the same time
they're like
mario party online no i've never heard
of that oh
you just said you just said three
magical words that i didn't think i
needed to hear and then i was just like
why why why have i never thought of this
before it's like that meme of like
whisper the three sexiest words into my
ears
i can't believe they released super
mario party on like two in 2018
yeah and it didn't have online play and
had like four maps
and they were [ __ ] sorry i yeah i was so
disappointed because i [ __ ] love
mario park i mean my body's still good
land
but yeah you know online would be
[ __ ] amazing i don't know
okay do you feel that some part of the
married party experience is being next
to each other and just
ah i get that but i would like the
option to play online for streaming
right if i need to
but also like you know it's the same
thing with like smash right like yeah
playing smash
land like next to your friends and
[ __ ] on them irl is fun as [ __ ]
yeah but they we very quickly found out
that online is also just as fun
it's gonna sound like a discord call
like that's fun as far as it's just sad
i mean i i feel like
they just hate happiness sometimes it's
like and i thought when when super mario
party released it's getting way too much
detail they had like four maps and they
were all mid and i was like okay well
they'll release new ones right they'll
update it they'll have dlc
right like i'm a [ __ ] liar yeah so
that never happened so i guess
[ __ ] dude i'm so sad about that that
game could have been something good
i'm always just hoping next mario
parties is the one that's gonna be
online because i think
the thing is the problem with it is like
everyone else is playing jess and
they're just playing [ __ ] hungry
hippos or something like that
and sometimes sometimes it's [ __ ] fun
as [ __ ] but other times you're just like
can you just go back to like a little
bit of chess you know like
play by the rules just a little bit you
know i don't get it because
you know we live in japan and they they
develop the games i do not know of any
japanese people who go around to each
other's houses
what do you mean you never hear of
people japanese people
meeting in their other people's houses
it's always an izakaya or another place
yeah maybe it's just because you don't
have that many japanese the ones i do
have never do that
oh i do that with my japanese friend do
you actually yeah i stand correctly i
mean not obviously not this year
but nowhere near as often as like going
out to like eat in an izakaya
oh yeah of course but like there's been
a lot of cases where i would go out to
eat and then we would go back to
someone's place yeah right but it's like
i feel like in in the west right we are
like 90 of the time it's like meet up at
each other's house get
you know future yeah because it's
[ __ ] expensive to eat out in the west
yeah yeah whereas here it's like just
like
yeah it's like the opposite where it's
like i feel like for a country that
should value what seems to be like
online play more yeah
for some reason they don't include it no
because they don't need more
like reasons to stay at home that's
that's already a big enough problem
they're like this is how we get them to
[ __ ] invite them
why is merlin's face like look like i
said something super racist
mario party and chill
they don't have netflix they'd rather
create like the next [ __ ]
tron vr sex machine toy than the word
mario party online let's be honest guys
what was the thing we were talking about
before again it was the
it was the tengah that the tank operates
with vr
yeah yeah yeah have you seen that no
it's like
so for to explain i can't believe i'm
explaining tango tenga
so tenger is just like an owner hole or
like flashlight a fleshlight a
fleshlight basically you see
a penis in it but it's but it's branded
so it doesn't look like a fleshlight no
it's like really way too overly stylish
it's like
it's a classic uh it's a classic it's
like a deodorant bottle yeah it's like a
classy pocket [ __ ] that's what it is
we're gonna call it that first first
class
i hate that word pocket [ __ ] that's why
i feel
it a tenga right just call it a tango
yeah but basically tenga came out with
this thing where
it would it's machine operated with like
ai in it
and it works in tandem with vr porn
so you'd be watching vr so you put this
thing on your wheelie
and you don't have to touch it at all
you start the vr pawn
and the thing will move in time with
what you're seeing on the vr pawn that's
funny i don't want to man i'm just like
i don't want that i don't want that
go to a brothel bro that's the first
thing i think i'm like just
at that point just go get laid by a real
person please
that's that's like you're probably
paying more for that tech
i think one session out of bro do you
feel like they're you know going to a
brothel is a bit different i think
you gotta you gotta you know you gotta
be the kind of person who's like i'm
gonna go to a brothel
i get it you know you're probably if you
want sex that badly but you're too
shameful to go to a brothel i get it
you're gonna pay like well i don't know
20 grand
then it's in your house right right you
should never have visitors over yeah
exactly
what is that what is that like medieval
device you have in the corner
oh that's that's my section no i dude i
saw like a video of it it's straight up
looks like a torture device if you don't
know
if you don't know what it is i'm good i
saw that on the news they had a thing
here where
the government was commissioning like ai
companies to like match people together
because the birth rate is declining so
low but then i also feel like
that's going into like dystopian worlds
yeah but then i i'm george
yeah yeah you can't have a world that
exists where we're ai matching each
other but then also having
sex machines that cater for your every
need yeah why would i
why would i sign up to the ai management
like 50 shades of grey in like 2050 is
just like this guy
just brings out his vr sex machine
why would i sign up for an ai matchmaker
which tango would you like
he's not romancing a real girl he's
romancing an anime girl
why would i need to sign up for ai
matchmaking when i have the like
kumtron 7000 in my office you know what
i mean what even would the ai determine
like how do you even determine that [ __ ]
i don't know what did you see your star
signs seem to be matched very well
capricorns and sagittarius tend to [ __ ]
very rough knowing knowing the
japanese it'll probably be something
like it'll be yeah
it'll be blood type earning and male to
female and it'll be
right that's good you're compatible with
half the population fantastic
nothing has changed i don't get japan's
obsession with blood types man that's
weird
oh yeah what is i don't you know your
blood type i don't know i don't
know i think
is that good well i mean i know there's
three different types right there's o a
b and a b
yeah yeah one right a b is the real one
i mean i i should know because i have
like a blood disease so i i used to have
a medical bracelet
yeah you probably shouldn't you know you
should know shouldn't you i just have a
medical bracelet
uh that would be like you know if i if i
i'm bleeding please give me this thing
specifically
do you know what your parents are uh no
but then i lost that i lost the medical
bracelet so i don't know where it is
so uh the one thing you probably
shouldn't lose i haven't got a
replacement it's been like a few years
now so
are you meant to like wear that always
not meant to it's just like a suggestion
from the doctor
what blows my mind what blows my mind
though is that in japan at least like in
japanese schools like
you can get bullied for your blood type
that's right damn man that's
that's next level bullying it's like
it's like oh you're an a type that's
just racism with extra steps man
yeah that does sound like an excuse it's
like i thought he's a filthy old type
yeah
you can't hang out with us oh times
because you're an a type right and like
because
why why does everyone know each other's
blood type yeah i think i think it's
because like when you do like uh
health checks oh yeah we did that yeah
yeah
i haven't done mine yet it should be
written on your thing that was that was
so strong so so to explain since we're
starting with geeks plus we are
technically under their health insurance
and their company policy is that we have
to get a
health checkup once a year which
everyone in japan has to do is work
everyone in japan
twice a year okay twice we've been here
for
one year already mail in but we've
already had one checkup how does that
work
okay okay so we're supposed to go twice
but we've only just been once um and
it was weird because i it was weird
seeing how efficient a health
system can be yeah how long did it take
because i haven't gone yet it took about
20 minutes to get 30. it's like 30. okay
well so still that's
so in 30 minutes you do an x-ray
uh your blood pressure you get weighed
you get blood taken
uh you do a hearing and uh sight test
yeah you talk to a doctor who'll talk to
you
and then you do a cardiogram and a
cardiogram yeah wow 30 minutes
all inside it was like it was like speed
running we
we were speed running health checks and
they even had like [ __ ] splits as
well
because there's a gold split on that
x-ray x-ray split done all right
blood taking split let's go it literally
felt like that because it was like
because i was about like uh because i
had some problems with my forms i had to
fill out my form again so i was only
about like five to ten minutes behind
connor yeah and by the time i had just
like just started my
like i'm gonna call it a conveyor belt
because that's what it felt like it felt
like i was in chicken run being
processed
um so i was i i just started the process
and connor was almost done
wow it was the most efficient
because i saw the list of all the things
that get checked up and i was like oh
this is going to be like an old day yeah
you also have to pee the night before
and bring it with you which i just
always feel weird
oh yeah carrying a a violence
who knows what might arise so you go
into this room and it's like this really
busy place in like shinjuku which i
imagine a lot of people will go to the
world in japan
and then there's uh like you go to this
uh reception area there's like 12 desks
like come here you hand the form like
right go upstairs you go upstairs yeah
everyone's in like medical gowns yeah
like a really fancy office looking thing
right it's really odd
and it's basically just a small room not
even that big with like couches in the
middle
and then you can see the like sections
like it's a food court of like what's
going to do what
you can see everyone getting you can see
everyone you see everyone doing
everything yeah yeah and then
you they're like all right go in this
room get changed you put the medical
camera you come back in and then like
right
you have a number so you're literally
like a chicken in a farm it's like
actually chicken
like a piece of meat being like passed
around the different things
yeah you gotta get sanitized and so you
just they basically just come in they're
like
number 124 and then you go in and then
you just have to like
hopefully understand what they're saying
in general yeah they tell you
yeah it was just fast it was like boom
boom boom wow but i was like [ __ ] dude i
hate blood tests i hate getting my blood
taken yeah god i haven't done that in a
while
and then i was like i was just yeah yeah
yeah i got to do my next week
yeah that's fun it's fun is it no it's
not
it's it's as fun as a health check can
be because i it was something
that was so alien for me especially
coming from the uk which you know
pick up the nhs forgiving giving
everyone everyone free health care but
the price you pay
for that is that you have to wait for
everything yeah
yeah yeah and when i say everything even
just going to the [ __ ] gp
it's sometimes yeah sometimes you're
like you got a fever or something i've
phoned up my gp
and they're like oh we can't six days
yeah we can't book you in until next
week and i'm i'm just like
great i guess i'll just try to sleep off
this i guess
for an entire week and by the time you
can see the gp you've already most of
the time
you've already recovered yeah i think i
never see the doctor in london but i
booked
three times to see it when i was like
dying and every time before the
appointment i got better and i had to
cancel it
because it was like i'm already better
right it literally takes a week at least
in london it's even
it's worse but i remember like i would
like i think i thought i broke my arm
one time when i was a kid and i was
i was in the emergency room and i'm like
[ __ ] dude i'm gonna have to get an x-ray
and they're like yep so uh
come back in a week and a half and we'll
give you an x-ray and i'm like what
like what do i just do in a week like
what about my arm yeah like yeah
come back in a week and a half i'm like
but what do i do till then but like oh
just don't do anything to it i'm like
what do you mean don't do anything to it
all right what i should do for a week
and a half not move my arm that's
so stupid man well yeah and it was so
weird going to the japanese health
checkup
and they like they started off with the
x-ray because like when i think x-ray
i'm just like
in in my head i'm just like i'm not
getting an x-ray unless it's something
serious so this is obviously like the
big checkup this is the x-ray but no
they [ __ ] lubed us up lubed us up
with a [ __ ] x-ray man
like we went in there and we just like
they go please go to the x-ray machine
it's just like a a rectangle on a wall
and you just put your chest against it
yeah it's really odd oh because when i
imagine x-ray i
imagine like the light yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah i always had that it was
bizarre
i've never i've never had an x-ray done
before so yeah what was weird actually
was the
cardiogram which uh where you like i've
never had that before yeah i've never
had that before
it's like lie down on the bed and you
kind of feel like a mental patient about
to get lobotomized
because they put these suckers on you
they put these suckers on you and then
they they put these
appendages on your uh on your heart and
your arms and legs
right and yeah it just kind of feels
like you're about to get the bottom i
was waiting for like the electric shock
to come
i was like go hit me but no nothing
happened then they did they
like they had to lube me up as well yeah
yeah yeah yeah they just put like lube
on you because like i think i had chest
hair
all right so it doesn't go what maybe
yeah
what do you mean it's it's a natural
medicine
is uh i'm not talking about my in-depth
colonoscopy maybe
mainland's off screen just like blushing
which by the way which by the way like
the smallest details i was i was told if
you're over 35
every year you have to have a
colonoscopy really yeah every year you
have to have a colonoscopy
it's because it's because uh japan in
japan hemorrhoids is a really common
problem
i'm legit i'm legit serious like i think
it's i think i saw something like crazy
like one in
four men in japan have hemorrhoids yeah
conor was telling me afterwards that he
he doesn't want a colonoscopy because
he's
afraid that he'll it'll awaken something
all i'm saying is like what if i dig it
man
what are you gonna like crack a fat on
the [ __ ]
surgeon i don't know man
because i was i was momentarily confused
i was like on my way
i'm like which end is that
i'm like because i thought about it
would you rather something go up your
ass or down your throat oh yeah cause i
asked i think
yeah i thought he thought he was going
down your throat so they check your
throat or down like this
what's that called that's a different
thing something else and i was like i
was like totally down i'm like all right
fine put it on my ass
down my throat whatever up my ass no no
um then also when we were doing this
health checkup as well they would like
we had like the the blood pressure thing
which yeah
like the thing in it which also always
feels weird that squeezes your arms yeah
yeah
and then the doctor was like yeah you
did you did good on that and i'm like
what does that mean
what does that mean what is doing bad
i'm like i'm like
explain what did good means like your
numbers are good i'm like yeah explain
the [ __ ] numbers to me what is this
supposed to mean
i got that was like i put all my
attention into my arm to change my blood
pressure yeah i was i was doing
something like hunter hunter men [ __ ] on
that thing i'm like
heart rate zero you did like avatar
blood bending [ __ ] it's just like yeah
yeah
i will now make my heart rate zero so my
enemies cannot find me
then we got a blood taken and i remember
we were before we got a blood team we
were talking about you know
yeah we were talking about how the
japanese health system had we've had
we've all had pretty good
experiences with the japanese health
system because we all have like i don't
know why we all have like that inherent
fear that you know everyone's had a
shitty
shitty experience when they have taken
the blood and they've just missed the
vein
right yeah and that happened to me
that really yeah that like it was
foreshadowing that happened to me
because i
i knew it as soon as he stuck the needle
in because you know you you can feel it
when when like it goes straight to your
vein
it feels exactly like the doctor
describes it's just like a prick right
yeah and it just comes out
so he sticks this needle in and i could
feel immediately
that something was wrong because it was
like that's not a vein that's muscle and
you start feeling pain
and i felt sorry for anyone who has like
a needle phobia because i'm gonna
i'm not uh like so i can feel him like
kind of
twitching the needle around my arm and
i'm just like i'm just like how do i
tell him he's not there how do i tell
him it's not there
and he does it for like a full like
minute before he realizes
oh there's no blood coming out and i
look and i look how he's just pulling up
fat like yeah i mean
i look over and there's like you know
you know like the vial of blood
yeah there's like the viola the vile was
filled up that much
like the minute he was poking my arms
like scar tissue yeah
god [ __ ] done it man i knew it so i
felt so embarrassed i was like [ __ ] i
want to be cool and not like like [ __ ]
myself here
yeah yeah but then i was like oh god and
i was like oh no the nurse is cute oh no
i can't i'm gonna
i think with needles i feel needles are
the only time where you can bring out
your inner [ __ ] and just be like
i don't i don't know i i can't look at
the needle going in
i like oh i i have to look at the needle
going you do yeah
i i like it's on the contrary for me if
i if he's like all right we're gonna go
in and if i don't see it and i feel a
prick that scares me joey's
jerry's just like he's like it's going
in yeah no legit i have to go like
hard i'm just being like do it do it now
wait so what about wait what about
staring at you being like pierced helps
you
because i know when the pain is coming
what
you know what i mean like no no because
because when you're ex
then you're expecting the pain no no
what's worse for me is unexpected pain
where i'm just like i'm just chilling
with this like ow you barely feel it if
you don't look though
no no no i feel a more if i don't yeah
because that's that's like
have you have you ever like cut yourself
or have like an injury you don't feel it
all day
yeah and then suddenly you look at it
and you're like wow there's a cut and
then suddenly you start feeling it
yeah yeah that's me that's me a needle
really because every time i get cut it's
just like
a pain like i can't imagine seeing blood
literally gush out of my veins and
thinking
yeah that's uh that looks like it's not
gonna lie like during the summer for
instance like because like during the
summer your blood pressure is a lot
higher yeah
so when the blood comes out it kind of
just like gushes out and i'm just like
oh that looks sick
i like looking at that it's kind of cool
huh i missed one i remember
like whoa that's coming out of my body
[ __ ] i remember as a kid they would just
give me this like contraption that was
just like filled with like paint oil and
it would just like all of it would like
you would flip it over and
start playing like crazy yeah you should
do that to distract to distract yourself
because i was like wow look at that
thing going to look at the vial i'm like
whoa that's cool
that's weird i can't do that really i
was just like i put my hand on the table
i'm like
go ahead
why'd you have to like smack it i'm like
come on get ready boy belt in the mouth
yeah i'm like using mine we're using
mine
it was weird for me because because
normally when i get my blood taken i'm
used to it being like
uh like a private place if you know what
i mean
yeah i'm sorry so we had our blood taken
it's like a conveyor and i was just like
eyeing up the next guy
the guy next to me again three of us
right here
was getting our blood taken he was very
odd neither of us could look at the
look at the blood getting taken and we
just [ __ ] like met eyes and just like
all right well it's it's kissed yeah
it's like meeting guys in a urinal
but you know it's just like so this is
awkward how's your day going oh that's
that's a
that's you look like a no-type there
[ __ ] you like
what are you trying to say right trying
to strike up any conversation i guess it
is odd that we kind of
made it into a private thing in the west
right like does it really need to be
private getting your blood taken
like if i mean it doesn't but i would i
feel more i think i think it's that
people would prefer it right
like i prefer it but if if that means
that you know i get medical tests way
[ __ ] quicker in the uk yeah by all
means do my colonoscopy in front of the
other patients i i
do not mind like let's get this done
it's like oh you cracked the fat too
high if that means i can get it done 20
faster and i can get on with my day yeah
i'll i'll i'll get it i'll get my blood
if i faint in front of a group of 20
people who cares that's that's why in my
head i was like oh this is going to be
an all day thing
anywhere else is definitely an all day
thing right yeah yeah well i think the
worst part was that you couldn't eat
uh or drink anything the night before oh
really after like 8 p.m you have to stop
eating and drinking and yeah
normally that wouldn't be a problem but
when you tell me i can't eat and drink
i'm like well [ __ ] now i want to well no
i want to just wait you can't even drink
water are you drinking
i was going to say that but water's the
only thing you can drink alcohol
yeah basically no substance like in your
bloodstream
um substance yeah what are you what are
you taking
god god's like you gotta put the belt
and spoon away
yeah that's god damn it they're going to
see my heroine veins and everything man
please make sure to hit the heroin pain
don't worry i got this i've done this
before
i'm kidding
in case you don't get sarcasm none of us
have done heroin okay
yet unless that's that's the the dark
arc of the trash table
trailer trash table stop joking oh my
god i heard you guys had an exciting
taxi journey yeah so i i convinced joey
to get a taxi because joey wanted to get
the train home because it's about like
half the price
but you know it was like midnight it was
the day where connor and i were
streaming at the trash chase office if
you guys saw on our twitch
yeah but it was like 11 p.m when we
finished yeah and i was like [ __ ] get in
the train home come on j let's get a
taxi here let's be comfortable let's
you know it's late you know we destroyed
you i don't know why you like have this
massive thing about like
the comfort in taxi it's not that much
it's not comfortable it's just that much
so much more comfortable
you say it as if it's like business
class versus economy honestly that's the
way i see it like no
no because also right now with the rona
going on i don't if i can avoid getting
a train i'll avoid getting the train i i
understand that
but for me like i would most like nine
percent of the time i would rather get
like have have a longer journey that i
can actually do stuff on because i can't
do anything on a taxi i like
i can do more on attack i look at my
phone and i immediately just get caught
up through anything on a train in japan
yeah i mean you can watch
youtube videos you can be on twitter no
no no no because i get carsick
because i don't know why i'm sorry that
your natural selection didn't favor you
jerry that's not my problem
well i'm not the only one getting asked
to do that yeah i don't think this
cast yeah is what i how do you get i'm
focusing on
the the youtube video whether it's
because it's because you can't see
outside so the inertia just [ __ ] you up
yeah because that's how you get casting
i'm not sure about the exact signs of
car sickness but i've
like cars are the only vehicle i get
motion sickness in yeah anything else i
can like
read i can vote boats well that's not
carsick is it it's yeah that's just a
vehicle
i don't think i get seasick really yeah
i get c6 i guess slightly seasonable
because normally people who are carsick
gets seasick yeah yeah i mean i don't
get carsick that
easily though unless you're watching
something unless but if i'm looking down
on my phone or like i can't yeah no no
like like i i don't get car sick if i'm
just sitting there
listening to me hell then
yeah that's why i i think that's why
i've conditioned myself to be able to
sleep so
easily in cars yeah because i literally
can't do anything in cars but
listen to music i can do the exact same
thing on a bus and not get sick
on a bus yeah i could be on a bus and
watch youtube
or whatever i will read i can look at
that [ __ ]
but i can't but i but if i do that in
the car i think it's five minutes in
i think it's the smaller the vehicle the
more likely i'm
to get sick i don't know what the
science is behind that yeah but if it's
like a like this if it's like a small
taxi
especially if it's a small taxi and
we're like squeezed in then
the back seat right and if you're in the
backseat yeah i just get immediately i
don't want to go in the front of the
taxi i don't want to i don't want to
make eye contact with the taxi driver
you don't have to
what do you think you're just going to
[ __ ] do these things sometimes you
know you might find yourself wandering
and you look at him and it's an awkward
moment of like
hi i did no i never driving good driving
what do you like i'm awkward i don't
want to make eye contact
i have the same problem in the back seat
where i accidentally sometimes look at
like no
that's the way i say sometimes look at
the rear
the worst is when they're a [ __ ]
awful driver as well you gotta pretend
like they're doing a good job
and they're just [ __ ] yeah and that's
why i prefer to be in the front because
i'm less likely to get sick in the front
from [ __ ] driving yeah
in the back because you're [ __ ]
thrown around in the back anyway the
story so
yeah we were talking about the [ __ ]
things yeah okay let's go back into taxi
yeah yeah so anyway so connor was like
look it's
it's 20 minutes home on a comfy taxi
it's quicker by only like five times
closer to our house because we don't
have to go to the station
walk right not that much yeah so i was
like all right [ __ ] i'll humor your
taxi ride
so then we get in the taxi taxi's
driving fine
and then we go on to this like kind of
bridge thing
and uh and then just some random police
officer just
walks out onto the street and kind of
flags us down
right and tells us to go into one of the
roads and immediately the
taxi driver was like does the japanese
equivalent of oh [ __ ]
he's like this nine year old dude just
being like oh
[ __ ] and he pulls in and connor and i
like what the [ __ ] is going on
and i asked the taxi driver i'm like
something wrong and he's like
i was speeding i was like
what you got stopped for speeding and
he's like yeah i was doing 80 down to
60.
and this [ __ ] old dude just like
walks out of the taxi [ __ ] like
you know aussie osborne stuff just like
kind of stumbles out
like four policemen surround this like
old poor old man yeah
and like in the middle of the night is
he's filling out this paper work and
connor and i just kind of sitting there
being like
oh we could have been home by now if we
weren't on the train huh the one time i
humaned this man to get on a taxi listen
the first time i've ever had a taxi
driver been pulled over by the police
you know
because i was like i was like i was just
hoping that they wouldn't be like all
right let's have a look what these these
boys in the back look pretty foreign
let's see what's going on with esports
yeah yeah
i was like far come on yeah no i i was
afraid that might happen as well so
immediately like before the police
officer even
started talking to us i just immediately
busted that japanese being like what's
going on
yes i am japanese they they the police
officers asked us they were like is it
okay if we stop you for now
like the driver yeah yeah yeah yeah and
i was like what what
what if we said no yeah i'm like what
are you supposed to say to that like
we're in the middle of [ __ ] nowhere
there's no taxis anywhere what do you
expect us to do like they pulled us over
over some bridge so there wasn't like
much there so it was just like some
water
right like a bunch of like a power plant
nearby so it was like nothing it was
really odd
so four police officers like [ __ ]
down this decrepit
there's two other police officers just
standing there doing nothing because
that's what they do here
every police officer every police store
i've heard in japan is
is all about how many police officers
you need versus how many was actually
needed
they literally sent like six police
officers to like you know someone
falling over on a bike yeah it's like
it's insane they're so bored here they
have nothing to do
yeah or they need you know spotters
right
i got you bro nice policing you're doing
this
yeah because normally in the uk it's
always like two people like it's always
a squad yeah exactly but one yeah one in
your partner right yeah that's normally
how it should be right and you don't
because also this i i don't know if this
is on purpose but it's very intimidating
when four or five policemen are crowding
around you and you haven't done anything
and they're asking you questions they
all look pissed off and i'm like well
come on
what's going on here then yeah all right
i thought i saw this about i felt so bad
for the old dude because he
he looked like he was about to get
[ __ ] and beaten up by his police
officers
because they literally was just crowding
around him just like looking down at the
paperwork
i've never been in this situation as
well this is the first time where i've
been
near police where they haven't asked for
like my id and like information stuff
yeah
because yeah because i busted out the
job yeah yeah yeah yeah it's so annoying
because you just go near them and
they're like hey we see id and all this
and i'm like why
i'm not involved in this i'm literally
just a customer leave me alone would you
think i had a gun pointing to the side
yeah do it do it do it do it you should
cut it
oh yeah no like what
stop playing europe in the background
hey come on guys
drift this corner i know what i'm doing
i know what i'm doing
this video is sponsored by mack weldon
there's a lot of things that you'd
probably like to leave behind in 2020
one of the most important being your old
underwear
if you're rolling into the new year with
the same bunching chafing and
uncomfortable underwear then you've got
to check out
mac weldon mac wilden is an essential
piece of my daily routine
thanks to this card holder boys that
holds all my cards very neatly thank you
mack welton i have a face mask
because i'm scared of the outside that
should you be wait god what is that that
you're wearing is that that
welding it is a nice little mac world
and fleece because it is winter right
now
and it is cold outside i just want to
feel comfortable looking fly
thank you very much matt galton has all
the men's essential covered socks shirts
hoodies underwear polos and active
shorts mac weldon promises comfort and
consistent fit
with versatility that look great and
feel great from working out going out
going to work or even going on a date
weldon is for everyday life don't forget
about the wide range of technology
what the [ __ ] are you doing don't forget
about the wide range of technology of
customized fabrics that can keep up with
you
no matter what your day looks like 18
hours
silver air knit drying it warm knits a
lot of nits but did you also know got
this wild and blue totally free loyalty
program
level 1 gets you free shipping for life
once you reach level 2 by spending 200
you get 20 off every order for the next
year gone
get out on top of that there is the
guarantee that mac weldon gives you do
you know what that is that the mac
what is the backboard well i'm glad you
asked mack weldon wants you to be
comfortable gone so if you don't like
your first pair of underwear you can
keep them and they'll still refund you
no questions asked even if i've worn
them before especially people even if i
need it too sure you've been a little
dirty gamer boy not going to the toilet
for 20
off your first order visit macweldon.com
trash taste and enter promo code trash
taste that's macweldon.com trash
taste promo code trash taste for 20 off
mac weldon reinventing men's basic don't
steal this line from me
thank you to mac weldon for sponsoring
this episode back to the show but in
general
uh i i do find taxis a little i don't
know awkward
i don't know there's somebody again who
thinks about things a lot socially i
like to think of like the perfect social
situations
what's what's awkward about them yeah
well i don't know okay well actually
talk so highly
of taxis right in japan in japan it's
good because i know they'll they'll
actually know some of them do actually
try and talk to me yeah that's not
saying none of them would talk to me but
some of them some of them will
i i feel some of the older ones they
bust out of conversations yeah yeah some
of some people who
also like maybe learned english in
college especially i've noticed taxi
drivers in the countryside
to me oh yeah they love they love
talking yeah yeah in the city it's just
like all right
you're a customer i am a taxi driver i
will not communicate in any way
it's charming um in in japan i think
when the taxi driver is trying to talk
to you because
especially in english when they try and
talk to you it's like oh damn you were
you're putting on the work but please
focus on driving but you know go ahead
the best the best taxi driver i ever had
was in um it was in okinawa
and uh we were going from what
constitutes a good taxi driver yeah
that's a good question
yeah yeah it was a good taxi driver do
you like it when your tax drivers talk
to you
sometimes i gotta be in the right mood
yeah yeah same here like sometimes i'm
just so [ __ ] like you know if it's
like [ __ ] 3am right yeah and i'm like
either drunk or just tired or both yeah
and i'm stepping in i don't want to have
a [ __ ] conversation with the texture
yeah yeah some sometimes sometimes you
get a taxi driver and they ask how your
day is going and i'm just like
i'm just saying can you not control by
the way here we go
here we go i mean it depends if i'm
alone or with friends have you ever
have you ever had a taxi driver who
bought into a conversation between you
and friends oh yeah
that i hate that yeah yeah i'm like hold
on hold on
this isn't a social invitation sir
the best taxi ride i had was in okinawa
because we were we were going to go
we were going from our hotel to this
like one uh castle
in naha and it was like a 30 minute taxi
ride
right um and the dude was like you know
obviously an older
gentleman yeah but he clearly had been
there his entire life so
and he knew immediately he's like oh
foreigners you clearly
don't know a whole lot about this place
huh and he started talking and he took
us on this really
[ __ ] scenic route oh like throughout
all these like
places but he said he's like i took you
on the scenic route but i'll charge you
for the regular
oh so he was nice enough so he would
like actually like kind of stop the car
and kind of be like this is this and you
know
that mental tour guide
i actually had something very similar
happened to me when i went to koshi
valley because we wanted to go to the
taxi drivers just part-time like [ __ ]
tourists
i think they're just happy because they
just have one they're happy to have
tourists there yeah
because i'm pretty sure business has not
been banging this year yeah um so yeah
we
me and sydney were on his taxi drive uh
on his taxi ride to get to this winery
and he's like let me give you a tour of
the other wineries in the area as well
just in case you want to go
yeah yeah who you want to go to and yeah
he only charged us for the taxi ride
to the one winery but yeah we got a tour
of like
everyone right now just show me these
taxi drivers i mean again like i feel
taxi drivers like that though really
only exist in the countryside
yeah dude in tokyo they're [ __ ]
miserable yeah
yeah i would be too to be honest i also
there's uh
what's the oh it's in roppongi there's a
big cemetery
um i'll find it oh yeah yeah you know
what the name of giant i'll send you a
picture of mudan but
um there's this whole area right next to
this giant cemetery right there's a
big stretch of road yeah taxi drivers
just sleep there
really there's hundreds of taxis parked
right
and they all park and they all just
sleep and like change clothes
in this area it's on a busy road in a
really busy area right
they all just sleep there that's so
bizarre yeah you can do that here you
can just park your car
on the on a busy road and you sleep yeah
like people do that
it's so weird yeah you can't do that in
the uk
no i feel most countries you can't do
that no even in the countryside that'd
be weird someone would like come and
stop you be like yo you're okay
have you by the way seen i couldn't
[ __ ] believe this but have you seen
uh those like rare taxis that you can
get in tokyo
rare taxis i can't believe japan has
actually done this but
they've literally turned taxis into
gacha
like of course they have of course i
forgot the exact name of it but i think
it's called
like sakura taxis right so you know how
like in most taxis in tokyo and this is
only a tokyo thing
uh but like you know how on taxis like
they usually have like the signs on top
of the car yeah like show
you know whether the taxis open or
whatnot yeah apparently out of i think
like the
7 400 taxi cars in the greater tokyo
area
there are five taxis that have
like a sakura thing on top of it yeah
and supposedly that's like the ssr of
taxis
and it's like and and what did you get
no because one of my because one of my
friends actually got it the other day
yeah um and when you enter into the taxi
it's a lot lot
nicer and like actually like first class
of taxis and inside there's like a
little sheet of paper that says
congratulations you found one of five
ultra rare taxis [ __ ] i hate that i
think that's so [ __ ] cool yeah i
think that's so [ __ ] cool and
i'm just like i really want to kind of
go around now trying to find this
[ __ ] mythical taxi this ssr taxi
dude my [ __ ] my my [ __ ] gotcha
pool it's the gacha pool of taxis now
oh my god already he's like oh my god
like every time you use like tokyo taxi
yeah you're just like
come on give me the give me the ssr give
me the s
what is this like a naught naught one
boy or something like that
[ __ ] it i'll give it a go why not all
right congratulations let's get more
taxes
just calling them taxi after this house
and they're all just parked up
are you the reason i see it no don't
worry i don't need a taxi it's like
[ __ ] his blue bag blew back he's like
come on give me the gold bag give the
gold bag
well i just think that's so [ __ ] cool
that like that's just like one extra i
guess like piece of enjoyment you can
have as a taurus right like
knowing that now when you come to japan
and you go on a taxi
like you can you can look forward to
that being like finna pull the ssrs on
taxis
it's the one reason that's the tourists
used to use a taxi because god damn
they're expensive injury
oh in tokyo they're [ __ ] expensive
they get pissed off if you take a short
journey yeah yeah yeah i've taken
sometimes i've had like too much [ __ ] to
carry so i've had to get like it's like
a short walk from the station to my
house but
i remember like a few times and i've
gotten the taxi because i had like too
much stuff to carry
they were like oh there okay oh here
and then i said yeah yeah and then i say
like thank you when i leave and they
don't say it back and i'm like
wow okay in japan that's like the
biggest [ __ ] you yeah
didn't say thank you back the audacity
that's like the equivalent of flipping
the boat
literally yeah i didn't realize that
until someone pointed out that it
happened another time as well they were
like wow that was really rude i'm like
well is he yeah
i thought he was just driving well he
didn't say thank you back whatever what
a [ __ ] what a [ __ ] [ __ ] the first
time it happened was a similar situation
where it was like a very short journey
it was like
an eight dollar journey yeah yeah yeah
and then i got out and
the other person with me was like wow
that was so rude and i'm like what was
rude
he just drove us he didn't say anything
he's like yeah i said thank you you
didn't say it back i'm like yeah oh okay
okay the audacity of this [ __ ] i'm
afraid to get back in that car and give
him a slap you know
like no but like that's the thing it's
like it's just tokyo taxis that are just
so [ __ ] expensive because like
if you think about it catching a taxi in
tokyo is a luxury
because trains are just so [ __ ]
convenient tokyo whereas the moment
you're out of the greater tokyo area
a lot of places without a taxi yeah yeah
it depends i think it depends where
you're going because there's some
if you're on the outskirts of tokyo
right sometimes going if you're going in
like an art like a
quarter circle let's say they don't
really have trains that go like like
london right it's the exact same where
trains go in and out
and they don't go around normally right
right so if you want to go the outskirts
not some most the time to get like just
you know a 15-minute taxi drive away
it might require you to go in all the
way to central and then go out yeah yeah
that's like 50 minutes and yeah
well you know how much is 45 minutes of
my time worth of 30 minutes
right but i think like the majority of
people central tokyo
care about that right yeah yeah if
you're like you know going to
whereas in okinawa there's literally one
tram line that goes for
five stops and that's the only train
line that they have on the entire island
so that's why the taxis are like half
the price that you get in tokyo
yeah if the people rely on it the local
government will yeah
like the 30 minute tax free ride in
auckland i was talking about was like
2000 yen oh [ __ ] seriously yeah it's
really really in tokyo that would be
about
like 60 70 bucks i'm convinced
that's right that in tokyo they don't
they don't make people retire they make
them become taxi drivers
most taxi drivers when i see a young
taxi driver i'm like wow you've made a
career choice
you made some examples of career choice
here what's going on because i speak to
people and
they like i swear to god they look they
look at taxi drivers like mcdonald's
workers here
yeah like it's like it's it's uh because
yeah because it's like you don't need
any qualifications except thrive which
you know they expect you to do yeah it's
just like a throwaway job that they make
or gsans do
yeah yeah basically it's like i've i
think the average age of a taxi driver
here is like seven years it's like you
can retire or you be
in japan yeah you need to see yourself
retire or become a taxi driver it's like
it's either taxi driver or like a
construction worker but not actually
construction just like holding the signs
and being like this way please
it's nuts how fast they build houses
here it's like crazy
yeah we had a we had like a whole school
bee built right next to the apartment
i'm living in
in the span of the year i was living
here which is [ __ ] insane
they built a full like three-story house
next to me in like two months
[ __ ] i was like what the [ __ ] what
the [ __ ]
no it is crazy like especially like say
when you go into like the city or
whatever
and you haven't been for maybe like a
couple of months it's surprising the
amount of things that have changed
yeah like oh this building was
completely different two months ago
yeah that was just magically here going
back to taxi drivers though
have you ever had any weird or like bad
taxi
experiences worldwide oh yeah definitely
in europe i've had some pretty
europe shitty taxis wait where where in
europe france
oh oh was it taxi taxi and
uber the worst uber rider ever had was
in france i don't know why all the weird
taxi experiences i've had have been in
la
like really yeah yeah yeah i've i've
only had like taxis or ubers
ubers ubers right i like when they talk
to you in l.a that's nice
uber's in la i've always had like a
pleasant time it's it's it's
it's weird because i've i've for like
the most part
i've had very pleasant experiences with
uber in l.a yeah but
there's this one there's sometimes i get
a really odd experience and it's it's
okay so the oddest experience i've ever
had with uber in l.a it was uh during ax
time
and we were all we were it was me and uh
two other friends and all we were doing
was we wanted to take a taxi
to the convention hall and this was late
at night by the way so it was uh it
wasn't like the daytime it was like
let's say 7 8 p.m so it's kind of night
time the time
the sun was down so we get we we call
this uber
and this like this car just rocks up and
it's like a [ __ ] decrepit
broken car like i was just like how how
the [ __ ]
has like how the [ __ ] has this passed
like uber standards i'm pretty sure
i'm pretty sure i'm pretty sure they're
like a dead body had been them there
yeah
you know what i mean so we so we're like
oh
this this is this is the uber oh okay so
we we were like whatever it's like a
5-10 minute journey anyway it doesn't
really matter that much so we're getting
this taxi driver and immediately he
opens his mouth and
you can kind of feel that he's he's not
all there in the head yeah yeah
he has a yeah he has a screw loose right
right why what was he saying
so i mean so at the beginning he was
talking about guys i gotta i gotta ask
you a favor can you can you please give
me five stars for my journey
all i'm asking for is one
way to ask for a positive review but
sure sure well that is not how you get
fired
so sure we'll give you a five star so he
starts starts driving to this convention
hall right yeah
and he puts it in the gps go to the
la convention center and then it says to
go
it says to go on a turning right yeah
and then it says please turn right
doesn't listen he goes forward right
right and then
he goes and then so it's fine the gps
corrects itself and goes
please turn right at the next turning
ignores that one keeps going forward
and in in between him ignoring this gps
and
getting further and further away from
the convention center because i was like
on google maps because i was like what
what the [ __ ] is this taxi driver doing
and he he goes and he he keeps talking
about this
[ __ ] five-star and one-star rant
right right he goes
if i get another bad review i'm gonna
lose it man
i'm gonna lose it you're like hovering
the one star
he keeps saying that i'm just i'm just
like making eyes because i'm sitting in
the front
and my teammate's sitting in the back
and i'm just trying to make eyes to be
like
oh you're in the passenger yeah yeah so
i'm just like yo if he
if he pulls the gun like you you got my
back right like if something happens you
got my back
and so the third time the gps tells to
turn right
and he misses it again and i'm just like
[ __ ] man something's gone wrong we need
to get out of this taxi right now
i'd rather get another uber than get
further and further away from safety
which is the convention center
and stay one second longer than this
taxi so we're like don't worry man um
we're close enough to the convention
center we can just we can just stop here
we can just stop here and he goes are
you sure
you sure and so we're just like yeah
yeah please please stop
please just stop here and so we get out
of the taxi and he
and um as i'm getting out he leans over
and he goes you're gonna give me your
five star right here we go
yeah yeah yeah five star five star five
star you promised
five star yeah five star and we're like
yeah yeah don't worry we'll give you a
five star
all right looking forward to that five
star drives off
instant one i was gonna say i hope you
can vote
yeah i hope it was a one star because
people like that i don't care how nice
you are you shouldn't [ __ ] be an uber
driver if you're pulling [ __ ] like
that's
that's
the equivalent of like getting a pizza
delivered and the guy being like twenty
dollar tip right you gotta give me at
least a twenty dollars
ten dollars no no twenty but i i could
very much see during that experience why
people gave him one stars because
i mean i i kind of feared for my safety
at one point during that taxi ride i
mean it's like it's not even a matter of
him just like ranting about like i'm
gonna kill a [ __ ] if i get another one
because yeah yeah it's the fact that he
wasn't even going the right way
he wasn't going the right way and like i
was like okay
at the beginning when he asked for the
five stars like whatever it's the
[ __ ] review i didn't give a [ __ ]
but when he was like i'm gonna lose a
man
i was just like oh [ __ ] man this is
[ __ ] terrifying
especially la you don't know what the
[ __ ] gonna happen yeah exactly oh
that's
pretty scary yeah i've never had
anything like that i i yeah i
sadly haven't had any crazy taxi
journeys really most of them are pretty
chill
i don't know i feel like it's really
hard to have a bad taxi journey although
someone gave you a one star once as a
customer on uber and i was confused
because really i don't think i've ever
done anything in a car but
maybe i did something that like ruined
this man's day and he gave me a one stop
oh wow
yeah i know i was i i had i had one like
really memorable
uh uber ride in la uh and it was again
from where we were staying to the
convention center it was like
again another like 5-10 minute ride yeah
and uh and this cup
this massive jeep rocks off right
there's only two of us i'm like okay
that's a bit overkill but whatever
jump in and it's just this like the
biggest black dude i've ever seen like
this guy like not not like fat like
built like he's got a [ __ ]
[ __ ] house right and he's just like hey
you jewelry right
like yup and it's like la convention
center all right i got you
like you know like super chill right
yeah and and so the car drives off like
two minutes later he's like
hey you mind if i put on some music i'm
like
yeah man whatever you want yeah yeah
it's like yeah man whatever you want
it's all good and he's like all right
cool it turns on something right and you
know there's a million different artists
you can envision
a person like that might listen to right
it's like oh yeah it's like you know it
could be any [ __ ] like hardcore
hip-hop whatever right whatever they do
[ __ ] enya comes on
hell yeah where
you always have a [ __ ] terry cruise
moment like white chicks
and i'm just like i i just started
laughing like i couldn't help but i'm
like if i laugh
this man might kill me but this is just
too funny and i'm like you like in your
honey he's like
yeah it helps me to relax dude that's
[ __ ] amazing
that was [ __ ] great full on respect
yeah it was so cool it's like
that's the thing though i didn't know if
he was like trying to make me laugh or
he was actually being serious but either
way i was like
you know what i can get into this this
is really cool
to you man it might be brick [ __ ] house
like listen or whatever man i'd have to
be an uber driver and just troll people
with music
oh yeah i would as well if i put my
favorite music on just blaze like
lucky star opening no if i get a new
drive if i become an uber driver anime
ops only
yeah yeah anime ovs only i was here as i
was hearing your story i was like have i
ever given an uber driver a one stop i
don't think so because
that was my only one to me it's like
five star is like
encompasses everything from the best
experience to my life to you got me
there in one piece yeah right four star
is like
you [ __ ] literally broke down you [ __ ]
yourself the the car stinks
yeah you've killed someone you you hit a
dog as well all right four stars
yeah yeah and then i've just never used
a one star i'm like i didn't even know
it was an option you know i thought
there was just two there's zero stars as
well right that you can give
is there yeah i think so because i
remember remember
what does someone have to do to get zero
stars i mean like
the one the worst uber ride that me and
aki went on was in france in paris
and this dude like uber and friends yeah
[ __ ] and this man almost
actually got us into a car accident yeah
french driver is a nuts dude yeah
i i remember he was [ __ ] shouting at
everybody in like the shittiest like the
kind of like start stop kind of driving
where i'm just like bro i'm gonna be
[ __ ] sick all over this car yeah
and he got us there and he was like okay
okay we're here
for you know whatever i'm just like all
right man zero stars
didn't you get uh you got scammed in
like italy right uh
yeah almost because like in like yeah
basically in
a lot of uh a lot of european countries
uh
except for like i don't know germany's
pretty good for it i mean a lot of the
like i think like prague is really bad
for it and places like that yeah where
like the taxi driver is
mad you scam you yeah and you got to be
like it sucks because it's the most
unjapanese thing ever but you just got
to be like
no i'm not paying that yeah oh yeah
sorry actual fact
yeah this is ridiculous yeah so we
landed in uh
in rome airport um and there was just a
dude
outside of the gate just being like taxi
taxi so no you're tourists yeah because
they are
tourists right and we were with aki's
parents as well so lucky's dad was like
yeah yeah yeah sure you know because
he's an uber driver
and he's like how much to this hotel and
he looks and he goes uh
50 50 euro and we're like all right
whatever so then he takes us to like
the back of the airport where like it's
like right opposite where the hangar is
right and there's just this van
and we get into this van and he's like
okay hold on i call my driver
and the guy [ __ ] off and we're left in
this van and the longer we look around
this van we were like
we're gonna get the [ __ ] out of this van
like this is this is not a taxi
because then i looked up like you know
standard
uh italian like taxi fest to the airport
from the hotel
yeah and we're like a normal like taxi
ride is like
20 euros yeah everything this dude's
charging 50. we're like
don't [ __ ] listen to those in europe
man like that yeah they'll they'll try
and get you away because it's always
going to be like an official taxi stand
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's always
good so we so immediately like we didn't
even wait for
it we just like grabbed our [ __ ] got out
went to the regular taxi stand and we're
like
all right thank god i mean i'm pretty
sure for like any country you want to go
to the official taxi stands yeah
well some countries have way stricter
rules on taxis than others and like
even if you get one somewhere random
you're pretty yes a lot of countries
you'll still get like i mean japan you
get you get it anyway you're going to
get
the standard fare right right same in
like uh germany and
uk as well i'm pretty sure it was
awesome but yeah yeah it's uh
yeah we learned that less than that
we're about to get i don't know where
the [ __ ] is
someone's vans literally what they warn
against as you're a [ __ ] kid yeah
don't get in any van ever
yeah it was it was fast as [ __ ] but i
think like the craziest in terms of
driving
taxi drivers i've had uh probably
in china i remember there was this one
taxi driver had in china where
it was literally like i was in a crazy
taxi game you know what i mean
like like this this guy this guy was
full on [ __ ] he
he might as well have just been like
drifting initially right
and it was like he was in the middle of
[ __ ] shanghai
and whenever there would be like
pedestrians on the road he wouldn't slow
down
he would he was like he was like tapping
his horn like it was a [ __ ] quick
time event
you know what i mean that's how like
like he's dodged yeah
like he literally had one hand on the
steering wheel and one and the other
hand on the horn
because that's how often he was tapping
it man oh my god i had never like feared
for my life
you go to chinese driving school they're
like right so roll the window down
pretty so you get rid of the shower
people
make sure your hand is always on the
middle steering is optional
jesus christ oh my god i mean you told
us about the story before about the
the situation that was not wiping right
right i've just had weird taxi jobs
it's just asia seems to have some weird
[ __ ] time that's just
that's just asian driving rules yeah
that's sure
which is why like you were talking about
bad taxi experiences in japan
for for like i don't think i've had even
like a bad mediocre experience in japan
everything
everything is just good got the job done
if anything the best taxi has
have been in like countries like japan
in japan right yeah everything's meted
you don't have to worry about tipping or
anything like that i mean sometimes
japan has been the only country where i
wish tipping culture
because i've i wanted to tip that taxi
driver who took me on a tour of
different wineries yeah
stuff like that i'm like please give
like let me give you extra money
yeah we were all fully prepared to like
pay the extra because it was taking us
around the scenic ride and he's like no
no no it's okay standard price i'm just
like
bro come on i want you to go home
tonight treat yourself
yeah exactly get something nice exactly
like speaking of like giving like
five stars and one stars and stuff like
that have you ever talked about what
like the reviewing mentality is here in
japan
it just tells us everything it's i
noticed that right away when i moved
here
yeah how like nothing on amazon is above
four stars yeah
it's not just not on amazon like
everything on like google google maps
yeah and stuffing if
like hardly anything is above four stars
yeah
it's it's like mostly is then it's only
like two reviews right yeah yeah yeah
yeah
and also like they have a so they do use
google reviews
uh mainly for like restaurants and stuff
but there's also a thing called table
log
that they like a lot of people who think
their food critics
use and it's just it's it's like the
yelp of japan basically
it's it's insane because it's like these
people review
these food restaurants and like three
stars for a restaurant is considered
good
yeah that's like it's done it it's it's
impressive because i remember when i
first moved to japan and whenever you
look up restaurants on google
you'd see like three 3.5 stars maybe the
occasional four yeah
and in england or in america when i see
a three-star restaurant i'm like
yo something's gone wrong if it's below
a four then i'm just like something's up
yeah yeah
someone found a rat in their food or
something man like i don't know i don't
understand yeah i don't understand what
that it's like do the japanese think
that the stars on google reviews like
michelin stars like
because i mean i understand it because
they actually i i respect that they have
a mentality where they literally
actually use
every star in the review system right
because it's like the male review
right where anything below like i'm
pretty sure like now below seven is [ __ ]
yeah yeah
i'm pretty sure like mao users don't
realize that like under five stars
actually exist
yeah um because it's either like seven
if it's good
um six is really bad six is really bad
and like
five is the most awful animation ever
like a restaurant
i the way i imagine it is like what
would i tell the owner if he was right
in front of me now
right would i genuinely sit there and be
like this is a three-star experience
because you know what i mean like
because yeah how are you going to do
that to the poor guys you should have
run a business right yeah because to me
you know if i go somewhere i really like
the food i have nothing bad about it
how in good faith can i be like yeah you
don't deserve five stars
yeah because there was nothing wrong
with it like this was exactly what i
wanted
i got what i needed yeah it wasn't fine
dining it wasn't crazy but like there
was nothing
oh sorry i was going to say like that's
the thing i want to ask about these like
super harsh japanese reviews right it's
like
what is a five star yeah yeah it's like
do you want to blow job from the share
cause this is like this is also another
thing where like
you how can you judge really a
restaurant the same way
mcdonald's yeah because like because
what was what i was going to say is even
like the fine dining restaurants are the
same
story yeah yeah that's because they
expect a fine dining experience
so if they get the fine dining
experience that's
that's that's standard that's standard
you've done the job and so that makes me
wonder
what the [ __ ] would a fine dining
restaurant have to do to get a four or
five star man
it's it blows my mind because like like
i said like comparing mcdonald's like a
fine dining experience
because they really shouldn't be on the
same scale right because
they're totally different things yeah
like so when you go to mcdonald's
what are you judging about mcdonald's
are you judging the place the food what
are you judging because the food isn't
going to change really
yeah it's probably not going to be any
different the only thing that determines
a good mcdonald's experience
or a bad one is like how fast the food
costs yeah this is what i see on google
reviews i'll see a two star mcdonald's
and i'll see a four star and i'm like
what is the difference
not like ultimately i cannot tell the
difference yes it might be dirtier i had
three less fries than i ordered
that's what confuses me because then i'm
then i'm also like okay
so if i rate this mcdonald's a five star
uh what am i rating it a five star on am
i rating it on a five star because
compared to other mcdonald's compared to
a bigger question
is who the [ __ ] is raiding mcdonald's on
google
who are you who are you people who are
that bored
i it must be the okay not to be rude but
you know people who are like yes it's my
only fine dining experience
i will review every mcdonald's i go to
people who call mcdonald's a restaurant
the same people call
motels hotels you know i've noticed that
every single
like really really high rated place in
japan
like four or five four point five or
higher yeah is normally like a
disgusting wait time to get the food
yeah yes because
when you get to that star in japan i
feel like you get like almost like a
fandom like a hype around you yeah a
cult following
yeah so then and then everyone starts
telling everyone it's like yo yo this is
four point five yeah you gotta go there
early you gotta line up and it's like
well [ __ ] now i can't enjoy the place i
gotta make a
three day events resume no i noticed
that as well where there's
japan's restaurant culture especially if
something is like highly acclaimed it
all spreads via word of mouth
where the japanese love lining up yeah i
don't get that
i mean as a british i mean i can
appreciate a good queue
uh but there's as a british person i can
appreciate a good queue as well but not
to a restaurant no you know what i mean
i can't [ __ ] stand cues dude yeah if
i want to if i want to go to a good
restaurant
that's exclusive please let me book it
please please don't
i don't want another gotcha system i
don't want to line up
i want just to have a booking and a
specific time i turn up
um or you could be like us and try to
book a
table at denny's completely
fail because we because we always eat
denny's before uh we record a podcast
and we had like uh one of the guests
over
and we're like oh [ __ ] that's a lot of
people we might have to book a table at
denny's so yeah we were like
which to give context it's like trying
to book a table at mcdonald's yeah
so maylene called up denny's and was
like uh can we book a table for
six and the guy came back and was like
what is this is a denny's why are you
trying to book a [ __ ] table just just
come to the restaurant please man this
is denny's
wasn't it wasn't it like he called it he
called like the manager or something
like wait
is yeah we don't have to
do reservations yeah making danny's it's
so exclusive you have to turn up on the
day
it's it's it's the most polite way you
can just say it's a [ __ ] denny's why
are you calling me
what the [ __ ] wrong with you so even
like going back to like normal reviews
with products like
all the products are like that as well
and like yeah if you see something with
45 stars on amazon with over like 20
reviews you're like damn this must be
like the [ __ ] yeah
because like oh they're paying for those
reviews yeah yeah true because i
remember when i was buying a like
going back last week buying a bed i
could not find a bed
over like three stars on amazon i
couldn't either i remember that
like there was no bed that was about
three stars and i'm like who how many
problems people having with beds and i
would go to the uh
the reviews to read what they were
saying and they were all saying that the
build was too long
and that was the problem that sounds
like your problem i've had i've had some
of the most pedantic reviews on japanese
amazon i've had like someone one-star
product because the packaging was bad
yeah completely fine the packaging was a
bit off so
they were like once that's what drives
me insane is that they they almost
always review the [ __ ] around what
you're actually reviewing yeah like all
the delivery man had a bad attitude
it's [ __ ] like i if the package is a
little beat up but the thing's totally
fine yeah fantastic are you gonna throw
out the packaging anyway yeah exactly
i don't give a [ __ ] like as long as i
can use the thing i need so what like
this shouldn't be a blight on the
company that send me it like this is
[ __ ] absurd i guess i remember
i actually brought it up to chris as
well because i was confused and chris
was telling me that ryotaro told him
it's something like
three is like what you expect
is good and then five is like like above
and beyond
yeah so he has to go to get five stars
it has to be beyond exception like
beyonce
whereas i think for me five stars should
be like all right this is what i paid
for yeah gave me exactly what i asked
for no problems
lifestyles i don't know weird weird i
guess it's difficult
how do you guys feel about seasonal
products here in japan
because you know every country in the
world has like
seasonal products and stuff but i feel
so
but yeah japan take it to the next level
whereas half the shelf sometimes i feel
is
like seasonal products yeah every
everything is seasonal everything is
premium as well i mean i i get it now i
meant i
remember they would talk about it in the
animes they were like the enemies
they're like you don't know the pain
until your favorite item has been
removed from the combini yeah
and i feel that because i saw that as
well so many items that i just liked
for some reason the the what the items
that i specifically like would just
randomly get removed yeah from the
completely yeah yeah i'd be like i'll be
like oh
it'll be back next week not gonna lie
every time i walk into a corn beanie and
i see something is like
new yeah i'm just like oh
i might grab one of those yeah i don't
know because like i
i don't want to try it i don't want to
get attached yeah that's exactly that's
exactly how i'm
feeling i've been like so many times
living in japan i go to a company
i try out this new like oh this like new
product that's only available for spring
because it's like the spring special
winter special products try it
absolutely love it and then
a few months later it just got
disappointing i'm like [ __ ] man i want
it now
you've given me a craving and you've
removed the craving and now i'm gonna
have to wait
all year for it to maybe come back yeah
for it to maybe come back because it
might not even come back i hate that
when they like bring out like a new
strong zero flavor
yeah i'm just like man this is way
better than the standard flavors too bad
it's only around for
two weeks and i'll never see it again
once it's gone because it's not just
like items sometimes there's like menu
items on
on in like restaurants yeah only
available during certain seasons
i mean i feel the biggest problem with
that is that the one thing in japanese
like especially supermarkets and
restaurants they
love to do that whole like seasonal
premium [ __ ] is with fruits
oh god right we've gone out we've ranted
about for sure
but like i remember like i went to uh i
don't remember
no i was a royal host i went to a royal
host and they were doing this like
seasonal thing with
grapes right like the green grapes oh
yeah like the muskets
yeah and i tried a few of them because i
like green grapes and i was like oh this
is really nice
went back the next week and it was gone
i'm like [ __ ] hell this is really
premium isn't it it's like
i swear it was only on the menu for like
three days and it's just gone
yeah i swear they they take like limited
time sales to like another level here
because
it feels like a lot of things are just
very limited
it's it's a limited edition something
it's limited edition products i mean
you know one can argue that that's like
very good marketing it is very good
people will look at something premium
being like well i guess if i can only
get it now i should get it now
it is it is kind of cool going into a
place and just having stuff be new
constantly but then there is also the
fact that like yeah i did really like
this one thing and you took it away from
me
yeah so i'm sorry it's like the same
thing whenever you travel to a new like
prefecture or something and there's
every pre like we talked about before
every prefecture has a specialty and an
item you can only get in that prefecture
every prefecture will tell you that this
is the best rice
yeah in japan so every prefecture will
tell you it's all the [ __ ] so like
definitely living in japan i've tried
more like i've gone out of my comfort
zone with trying
new products and new suites and new
views and everything but at the same
time i've just found more cravings that
i
can't get on a normal basis anymore
because it's only available from a
certain preference what was the [ __ ]
maple cakes
that we bought from yeah the manju that
we bought from like hiroshima oh
yeah those were so [ __ ] good yeah the
problem is you can only buy them in
[ __ ] hiroshima so it's just like cool
i'm not really a sweet person but then i
like yeah we bought those and i ate one
and i was like
[ __ ] i want to eat all of them
i like this stuff that i thought yeah i
only bought a tiny bag
could have gotten the pack of 24 but
yeah i got the pack of eight but you
never know sometimes you go
you go you try out this new thing you're
like it's it's all right it's it's mid
it's whatever right
but sometimes you find that really
amazing product and you're like [ __ ]
but then but then on the contrary isn't
it amazing when you find that one
regional thing that you think you're
never gonna see in tokyo and then just
one random shop sells it yeah yeah man
[ __ ] yeah like i remember like uh in
tochigi for example
yeah they have this thing called lemon
milk yeah which i [ __ ] love and it's
like
it was a regional specific thing for the
longest time and i was like
well [ __ ] i gotta make a trip up to
tortugi every time i want this yeah so i
would always buy it in bulk when i would
come back home
but of course it doesn't last right and
then the craving comes back and i get
[ __ ] progressions
but then i remember uh i walked into
like a random company once and they were
just selling it
right and it was like [ __ ] oh it was
like [ __ ] el dorado you know it's
like
the secret was here all along [ __ ]
bought all that [ __ ] and brought it back
and i was like all right no
put it on google maps this is the
company that sells the
the lemon milk man the the
sapporo special um thingy beer what is
it what's it called again
sapporo beer no no no no it's uh what's
the prefecture called hokkaido yeah yeah
we forgot for a second there
yeah hokkaido the sapporo beer is way
better when they have like the
the sapporo actual sapporo beer yeah
yeah yeah this is so good i want to
bring so much back but
it's heavy does it actually make a
difference i genuinely think it tastes
really better yeah
it's weird i think sapporo in japan
tastes worse than i remember it tasting
abroad i don't know it's it's it's weird
maybe it's cause i have it way more
often now but when i had sapporo like
on tap somewhere else i was like oh this
is so much better than the beer
that we that the other yeah yeah but i
think it's because you're comparing it
to other beers right like i remember
asahi tasting
infinitely better in australia yeah now
it tastes [ __ ]
but now i'm more scared to go back to
australia and have the [ __ ] beer in
australia i'm like
if i think osaki is mid now which used
to be like god tea before
yeah i don't want to drink a vb right
like i feel like i'm gonna throw up
drinking that [ __ ] because i can't
imagine going back and going like
drinking a
calling again oh god so they'll cuddling
is like
piss water in the uk yeah one of the
worst beers and there'll be sports bars
in japan that are like
we're partnered with carly
we sell carling and carlsberg i've seen
that before because uh
budweiser yeah budweiser yeah because
i've seen like
uh special special restaurants they sell
like this thai beer called singer beer
yeah and it's like in
in thailand it's like the dirtiest
cheapest beer you can get
like they don't even put it on tap they
put it in like they put in like a can
the tinies are the [ __ ] yeah yeah i
didn't in japan they they on a menu like
500
500 yen for a little can of singapore
yeah what you're what you're watching
from thailand yeah it's like who is
going to go
to japan and be like oh we have
exclusive heineken
in bottle 700 yen please it's like what
no
yo yo heineken in amsterdam is [ __ ]
great honey
is good beer wherever it's brood is the
best well yeah
like you know i had a [ __ ] uh uh oh
my god i'm
blanking here the irish one um
guinness island just hit differently
yeah it's [ __ ] amazing but then i had
a guinness here on top
because they were having it on tap so
i'm like i was curious i was like all
right well guinness in ireland is so
good
i do that every time as well yeah i was
like oh they have guinness on tap here
in japan let me why don't you do it just
to get hurt because
because because you hold out the hope
right yeah you hold out the hope but
maybe this is the one yeah maybe this is
the place it's like
it's like this pub might be the ssr pool
yeah
it's like this might be the one maybe
this is the one and every time i get
disappointed
i was like every time i see like irish
pub in tokyo i was like yeah
is that the one is that the one place
that i can go because it's not even in
tokyo it's worldwide for me and like
every time i see a guinness on top
because that's
never that can [ __ ] oh no but like it
has to be on tap because i'm like it's
on tap
maybe maybe this is the one maybe maybe
they figured out the secret and uh
i'm still waiting if if anyone in the
world has ever tasted the guinness
outside of ireland that tastes as good
as in ireland
i'm curious to see if there's any place
outside it doesn't travel well you know
that's the sad
truth of it gone it's like kangaroo as
well like that [ __ ] does not travel i'm
okay
i'm okay with that staying in australia
actually i had a kangaroo steak here in
japan at an outback steakhouse of all
[ __ ] places
just because i was curious and i was
like man this [ __ ] does not travel i i
found that out on that day
that kangaroo does not travel you know
what's also bizarre
uh when i was in uh hokkaido i was at a
train station and it was like
11 a.m yeah there's so many people
drinking beer
in the station yeah yeah like just like
everyone likes everyone every kind of
like
you know uh group you can imagine like
young girls old men
young men they were all just chilling in
the station just drinking a sapporo beer
yeah
i'm like i'm like this is weird
everyone's just drinking
beer at like 11 a.m what the [ __ ] yeah
it's in the train station like yeah
they're like public waiting areas it's
so big it's like that in okinawa as well
but instead of
beer it's awamori which is essentially
just really
[ __ ] strong it's basically okinawan
vodka that's the only way to describe it
because
i i forget sometimes about the public
drinking lawsuit
which you can drink publicly publicly
here because i feel like
i didn't expect to see so many people
drinking in the daytime in japan
like i i get surprised when i see an is
like izakaya open because i'm like who
the [ __ ] is going to an isakaya like 12
a.m
oh yeah you'll see them and they'll be
drinking a bevy yeah yeah exactly i
never i never thought that the the
concept of like
lunchtime beer was a thing here until i
saw it for myself
yeah and i was like wow they're actually
having lunch it's always it's it's like
you it's for people you don't expect
because it's always like the old people
yeah people were just like hey let's
just have a lunch time just crack open a
beer
like 12 p.m too far in the uk that's all
the old people do as well yeah
if you ever go to weatherspoons at like
midday you'll always see the same old
people
downing pints yeah at like 12 and you're
like it's okay they'll be asleep by four
anyway so yeah
doesn't matter like speaking of like
little seasonal and
regional stuff that you can only get in
japan has there been anything you've
like any little products or anything
you've missed from home or from any
other country at all
that you like actively get a craving for
no i have gone i know you have connor
my parents shipped out pot noodles to me
oh because i do like the ramen cup
noodles they have here i die
i die a little inside whenever i hear
connor say that yeah because
that's right it's not i don't i'm not
saying that
the pot noodles in the uk which should
be on screen are better than the ones in
japan i don't think that i think the
japanese ones are
superior in every way but there's
something familiar and comforting about
this it's nostalgic and also it's very
spicy which
unfortunately they're not that's hard to
come by yeah
yeah it's really spicy it's good [ __ ] i
love it and so my parents are christmas
because you know i you know ever since
you start making your own money it's
like right well i buy everything i want
for myself
yeah so they're like what can we get you
and i'm like well you can get me
something
i can't get myself right right and not
love none of that
so many pot noodles from the uk and
they're like hot noodles like yes
please send me pot noodles that's what
they did yeah i i always
i always ask my parents to send me like
uh like
australian sweets and stuff no you can
uh australian uh swears by them like
it's like national pride or something it
is national prize
i'm just [ __ ] awesome just a biscuit
oh my goodness
get out of here i just i i think biscuit
is like the most
underwhelming sweet like it's it's hard
it's never satisfying
it is like soft cookies are way better
than hard cookies yeah like
what do you think i get i get that i get
that but like we also have like
wait so do you guys consider tim tams to
be hard cookies no
biscuits biscuits oh hard biscuits right
yeah yeah yeah they're not soft
what's the difference because that's a
soft biscuit to us because we have these
things eating rocks for harvesting we
have these things called anzac cookies
which are literally
rocks like i don't want to have too much
break teeth you're trying to eat
i don't want to have to worry that's not
a cookie if i have to worry about
breakfast
it's a cookie if i have to worry about
breaking my goddamn teeth it's not a
[ __ ] cookie
antic biscuits are [ __ ] like
australians watching this one though as
biscuits are [ __ ] awesome it just
sounds like a health hazard it is a
health hazard because it sounds like
it's like chewing it's like dude you can
work out your jawline eating this
[ __ ] cookie like it's so
tough we had these growing up i still
have these in the uk obviously but
they're called digestives did you like
those
suggestions digestive biscuits
digestives yeah they're called they're i
realized that they're not appealing
i realize that's not very fitting yeah
they were awful like nevertheless
biscuit you can get and it's got like a
soft layer of chocolate covered on top
and the chocolate is [ __ ] chocolate yeah
the biscuit is like
just dry like a milk biscuit or no no no
no it's like a wheat biscuit yeah that's
what it looks like
oh god that doesn't look good at all
yeah because
you're supposed to like dip it with tea
and uh coffee and stuff like that but
then sometimes you dip it in your hot
tea and it falls apart and your [ __ ]
teeth ruined
yeah but you can do that with a tim tam
as well i don't want to put anything
but i guess there's too much chocolate
to put in the tv there needs to be like
a perfect chocolate ratio
chocolate to biscuit ratio because tim
sounds like covered in chocolate right
yeah yeah and that
if it's too much chocolate starts
melting on your fingers as you dip it
and see that's that's like you've never
had you've never done a tim tam straw
before
[ __ ] that's like a thing that you did in
australia so it's always like you
haven't got a flip
kangaroo here's something there's some
australian culture for you all right so
you get a team
so it's like usually you do with a cup
of tea or a cup of coffee whatever you
prefer you get a team time you bite
both ends off right and then you use it
as a straw to suck up your tea and
coffee
and it's [ __ ] awesome is this some
down under jokes
yeah like what
when is something a culture and when is
it just like stupid
it's what we do that's what some people
do i did it once and i was like yeah
that's cool i don't do it every time but
it's just a little thing you can do yeah
i don't know
um we gotta find our own fun in
australia right there isn't a lot to do
exactly all right but yeah i've like i
don't like biscuits
at all no it's definitely like the worst
i i'm not really fond of cookies either
i think cookies are over
it's just because uk cookies are just
[ __ ] okay no no no no no
uk the the [ __ ]
store brand cookies are always [ __ ]
fresh cookies out the oven when they're
like
they need to be soft and chewy
what i hate is if i bite on a cookie and
it crunches it goes everywhere yeah
and crumbs annihilate them if i have
crumbs
then i'm like this this is a [ __ ] cookie
this is just a biscuit with extra steps
you know what i mean biscuit with
attitude yeah yeah yeah i like my
cookies to be
gooey yeah i like it to be soft not
gonna lie i've never thought that deeply
about
excuse me because you know you grow up
in the uk you're watching american
cartoons and for some reason in american
cartoons cookies are like
like i don't know the the the thing that
fueled the world for
the kids generation cookies were what
the like the mayans used to
to barter and negotiate because they
these kids shows made cookies to be like
the godsend of like
everything so when i you know you grow
up and you can start buying your own
things you're like well
yeah i mean cookies are the best treat
when you start having them you're like
wait these are kind of
it's kind of [ __ ] it was it was always
like you know that mythical cookie jar
right there yeah
yeah yeah i didn't have it in my house
so i assume everybody else has
it it was just like cookies were like
insanely like valuable you know kids
were dying
fighting wars on the planet currency
because yeah literally it's you know
because like for me whenever i get like
baked cookies or someone who cooks fresh
cookies there's like as
soon as it comes out the oven the
[ __ ] timer starts because
when it's dry it's [ __ ] yeah exactly
because you because you've got to be
like 100 cookie speed right
i gotta i gotta like enjoy this before
it starts hardening and it's like as
soon as it starts hardening
it's one of the few objects in the world
where moist
is a positive adjective you know what i
mean
i get that yeah i feel bad when people
like make cookies like the day before
and they bring them
like you want to try one of my home
baked cookies i'm like i could i could
try one of your homemade cookies but i
will be sort of disappointed it's like
those and brownies like
if i have like a dry brownie um it's
it's like a it's like the limped
a drowning piece of brownies a brownie
does need to be a little like
like wet yeah yeah yeah yeah
if it all that just [ __ ] crumbles
apart when i touch it i'm like well
the structural integrity of this brownie
is appalling if it's flaky then
it's it's if it's not making like a
sound
you know if it's not making that sound
that it's a bad brownie
i can't be the only one who thinks that
no you it needs to be like asmr levels
of like yeah you don't like smacking in
your ears for example
do your supermarkets in australia like
have bakery sections or they would bake
things yeah yeah yeah we did they used
it like in the uk to be fair they used
to make pretty [ __ ] good cookies and
brownies
do you do i think so wait sainsbury's
like sainsbury's just have their own
bakery
okay so okay i've i've actually got i've
actually like i know the best ones it
goes
sainsbury's then tesco's then co-op
because those those are
these all sound like just made up names
yeah they do these are the supermarket
chains in the uk
and all of them have their own bakery
and yeah you get like four fat ass
cookies
yeah yeah yeah right they were always
like freshly baked on the day and soft
and
they were [ __ ] good they were good
you could buy the like packaged ones but
like why would you do that when you
could go and get like a full box of
brownies like 16 little chunks
yeah like a quid right now and they're
freshly baked freshly baked
really [ __ ] good yeah that sounds way
better yeah i i'll tell you what i do
miss that i didn't think i would
dairy milk chocolate yeah i like dairy
milk like because i thought whenever i
came to japan on holiday and stuff i was
like i was like man the
chocolate his bomb i [ __ ] love the
taste of chocolate here and then
after living here a year i just feel
like i've really
some something something homeless about
dairy milk they've taken the american
way of making
uh chocolate it does taste like america
because what they've done is instead of
having more milk
and making it like a richer taste
they're like let's just substitute with
more sugar
yeah yeah and then you get this kind of
weird chemically taste which i like
hershey's
does hershey's tastes like just in my
mind
like question marks with sugar like it's
like i don't know what this tastes like
it doesn't taste like chocolate it
tastes like a maid
i am not a fan of hershey's american
chocolate does not taste like chocolate
i i used to
like really like hershey's like i i
still kind of do whenever whenever i'm
like in the uk or whenever
it's not as rich so you can eat more of
it yeah because what hershey's tastes
like it tastes like
cooking chocolate right and i don't know
why i like the melting chocolate yeah i
don't know why as a kid i [ __ ] loved
cooking chocolate because
i it just it just like it's normally for
poorer quality yeah yeah exactly
it's it's poor equality but as a kid i
just like anytime we'd like cook
chocolate i just like
always have to dip my finger in it and
oh yeah
that's that's what hershey's tastes like
so as an adult eating hersly
like brings me back to being a kid and
then i have two bars and i'm just like
okay this is actually just [ __ ] it's not
good
america nostalgia gone it's just [ __ ]
chocolate now like americans man you
have a rough man i know we clowned you
guys all the time but like
your chocolate is [ __ ] awful please
like import some like milk
or dairy milk cadbury yeah cadbury
cadbury milk chocolate [ __ ] beef
yeah cadbury's dairy cat resists dairy
milk yeah yeah
it's owned by an american company yeah
but it used to be
i mean a lot of the british chocolate is
really good i think that's one of the
things we actually did pretty well
uh yeah i think chocolate in the uk is
really [ __ ] good i think chocolate i
live all over europe yeah yeah that's
really that's
pretty pretty good you guys get it from
europe honestly it gets
hella bougie and then like the rest of
europe and like like swiss chocolates
and stuff
okay it's [ __ ] great it's great but
it's like
it's like seven bucks sometimes it's
great and i can like but every time i
have a bite of swiss chocolate i can
feel the chocolate entering my veins
yeah it's it's a very rich depends
because i
like i think my favorite like big brand
swiss chocolate is like
lint i do like lint's really good you
gotta like sit down after you have a
bite you're like
oh it's [ __ ] great you're like doing
a pint of cocaine
you go on a journey when when you take
that one by man
you just like it needs to be like okay
when when like the truffle inside it's
just like the perfect consistency
when you bite off that hard shell and it
just the soft truffle and it's just like
ah
it's beautiful my mouth is watering just
describing it i [ __ ] love a good
ferreira
ferrero [ __ ] oh my god god damn herrera
is [ __ ] amazing milkshakes are like
the best thing ever
milkshake um ice cream ice cream is
[ __ ] like
you can like grind it into like a
milkshake and it's [ __ ] amazing oh
like diy
yeah yeah oh wow some places do it
really yeah well that sounds funny
i feel like i increase the class
whenever i say ferrero rush yeah
it's the most cautious word i've like i
can think of off the top of my head it
just sounds so good i feel the monocle
forming on my eyes
because i feel like you you don't you
experience swish chocolate you don't eat
swiss chard
you know what i mean you eat british
chocolate like it's saying you can just
eat
you know what i mean the swiss don't do
drugs they do chocolate yeah oh
man i sometimes i like buy like a pack
of lint and i'm just like
i'm i'm having i'm having a good day and
you eat all of the like lint package in
one go because i can't like because i
feel like i need a palette cleanser
every time i have like a rich chocolate
i'm like
give me the the wine to go with it yes
sir to empty the flavor
i have i have a like a problem where i
have one it's enough you have a sweet
tooth though don't you i do not have a
sweet tooth [ __ ]
only in japan actually only in japan
because here's the thing i
i hardly ever used to snack i either i
either was that guy in england who would
eat a tub of ice cream
or not i'll go over that sweets for like
two weeks like i
i there was no between for me like only
in japan
have i ever like kind of embraced
snacking culture and that's just because
there are so many different kinds of
sweets and snacks here yeah
like kind of want to try something i
used to be a sweets guy back in
australia but then when i moved here i
realized that japan's
snack or like confectionery section
there's a lot more
savory [ __ ] yeah that just tastes way
better than the sweet [ __ ] yeah
so i'm just i always just go for the
savory [ __ ] now it's easier to make
something that's
tastes good that's sweet though you just
[ __ ] put a [ __ ] ton of [ __ ] because
yeah but i also feel gross after eating
it right because if you ever come to my
house in england if you ask for like
anything that's not savory snack i'm
probably not gonna have it
because if i do have a lint like like a
chocolate
or like a lint box that's gone in like a
few hours most of the time
that's because i rarely buy but when i'm
doing i'm like i'm like super craving it
i don't know
i i mean i haven't had a ferrero rocher
in like probably like a year and a half
maybe do they sell them in japan oh yeah
do yeah yeah yeah you never see that
because if you go to like uh uh like
international shops
like they'll have it yeah oh because
like in in the uk that was like the
not expensive it's like the the if you
want to look expensive but not actually
spend too much money for error or shares
with the channel
it sounds fancy but the only thing that
isn't fancy is like the price tag i mean
they're expensive but
compared to like lin to lenore or
something like that right i've had some
super super you talking about lint and
ferro russia being like
i've really liked deep taste i've had
like shows aren't that intense
i've i've had some like the super
expensive chocolates are the ones i feel
like
you have to do you you're going you're
going on a [ __ ] battle with taking
your bite out
forever shares like the premium
i'm like yeah it tastes like [ __ ] ash
do you like dark chocolate i do but
there's a limit like right
like it's like ninety percent couch yeah
because you'll go to play in these like
chocolatier places and they'll be like
it's amazing isn't it and it's like
eighty percent like
and then you're like yeah that's great
it's good sometimes i have like one bite
and
i'm like oh i gotta [ __ ] battle this
like i'm having a [ __ ] battle with my
mouth like trying to get this down
like i get it if i was having like an
espresso or something to go with it
yeah perfect like they'll wash each
other out and you know i'll feel
happy but when you have one bite of
super dark chocolate
it [ __ ] stays with you for the rest
of the day yeah it does like think you
can't you cannot get the taste out of
your mouth
yeah and i don't want to feel like i've
just bleached my mouth i've never
thought about having chocolates with
like anything else actually really it's
with coffee it's like the best yeah you
gotta have it with the coffee i don't
eat chocolate that's just with a hot
drink
i don't know i find it because for me
like coffee and tea
i just like by itself i've never tried
because if you dip something
into the tea that root that kind of like
changes
i eat it you eat it when you drink it
it's like a palate cleanser yeah because
like
if your mouth's too chocolatey you can't
keep eating more chocolate i might want
to give that a go then because i've
only never thought to combine the two no
because i never yeah i never thought
about it chocolate and tea
like unspeakable like because chocolate
has always been a snack for me
at a restaurant at like a fancy
restaurant they'll be like coffee and
dessert
yeah yeah yeah i just like coffee and
chocolate
yeah because they go together it's like
i thought
god's just like wow i didn't i thought
you're supposed to eat all the chocolate
and then down your tea
are you telling me chocolate's meant to
be just a snack
i'm not just a dessert because that's
that i guess that's the way i see all
chocolates right
it's not a like i said i don't i never
used to snack it's like it was my
dessert i guess
it was it was like a full-on i'm either
committed it's very sad to have a
chocolate bar and be like ah yes
dessert my dessert my dessert yeah cause
like i
i actually like didn't start enjoying
wine because
as a kid or like as as like a teenager i
would say wine was like the one alcohol
that i just couldn't get into yeah
i didn't understand why people liked
wine and then i remember the first time
i tried
red wine or good red wine with good
steak and it was just like an instant
eye-opening moment for me man i mean
let's be honest you can't you can't
really enjoy wine unless you're a bit of
a disposable income really
and i don't know about you growing up
but parents were like think that's a
waste of time
unless you're here even before whenever
you know you've got
like your family or you're like one of
your rich you know
relatives whatever you try this try this
good expensive wine and the only thing
you can think of this isn't [ __ ]
worth 80 bucks
yeah [ __ ] kidding me and to be honest
i still think that i still think any
like i'm probably making some similar
cry here but i've never tasted like a
wine beyond
above than let's say 50 bucks that's i
that has tasted a lot greater than some
of like the best wine
yeah like a 60 wine tastes the same to
me as like a 200 wine yeah
exactly i mean i've had like you know
you can buy wine at convenience stores
here for like
as cheap as four bucks
i can taste difference between that but
like the more expensive quote unquote
wines that you can buy like a 711 is
like a thousand yen and those are
actually perfectly fine like i've had a
few of those where i'm just like
you know what this is actually pretty
good for a thousand yen wine it's i
don't know
it's good for combini wine yeah but corn
bean wine is the best you're gonna get
shout out to alpaca wine which is like
this that
alpaca wine is like what's like an
equivalent of like the cheap ones
echo fours is like the echo falls of
japan and in the uk it's a it's the
cheapest wine brand like a box wine
it's the uni but there is all the uni
it's about four pound for a bottle
right it's like always flavored like a
kid's drink
it's like lime and grapefruit and then
it just tastes like
antifreeze with grape hint yeah we have
that in australia just tastes like
washing detergent grape flavor yeah it's
[ __ ] delicious it's [ __ ] gross but
you know what else i'm grateful for what
our patrons oh my god they're awesome
look at all them
shout out to that guy on the screen
right they like eating chocolate and
wine
i bet they hate they hate hard biscuits
this guy's they think this gets mid
they hate taxi rides just talk about
everything we talked about and they're
like yes
anime themed cafe yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
didn't we thank you for joining us today
on the trash taste come on do you want
yourself
contractually because we have to say it
thank you fuel
for sponsoring this episode hey if you'd
like to support us on patreon go to
patreon.com also follow us on twitter
and subreddit and uh for
audio listeners go over to our spotify
and
yeah joey literally said everything that
i needed to say so
thanks for taking the outro thank you
for taking the host spot from you joey
so i guess i've been your host connor
[ __ ] i've been your host joey as well
bye-bye bye guys i wanted to say the
outro
you